et bien je déclare cette séance ouverte
mes chers collègues l'audition qui nous
réunit cet après-midi étant consacré à
une personnalité appartenant à sa
famille politique le président de la
commission d'enquête a demandé à ce
déporter le bureau accéder à sa demande
c'est pourquoi j'ai l'honneur de
présider cette séance
nous accueillons donc Monsieur Thierry
Mariani député européen rassemblement
national ancien ministre ancien député
chers collègues je vous remercie d'avoir
répondu notre invitation comme vous le
savez notre commission d'enquête travail
depuis plusieurs mois sur les possibles
ingérence étrangères dans la vie
politique dont économique et médiatique
de notre pays elle se situe donc sur un
terrain assez proche de la Commission
spéciale sur l'agence étrangère dans
l'ensemble des processus démocratiques
de l'Union européenne y compris la
désinformation et à laquelle je crois
vous avez appartenu
et donc nous entendrons le Président
Monsieur Raphaël Glucksmann la semaine
prochaine
pour autant si notre commission a
souhaité vous entendre ce n'est pas
seulement pour recueillir votre
témoignage en tant que député européen
vous avez siégé dans notre assemblée
près de 23 ans il me semble entre 1993
et 2017
nous quittons votre mandat que pour
participer au gouvernement Fillon 3
de novembre 2010 à mai 2012 les
élections législatives de 2012 vous
avouez votre circonscription du Vaucluse
que vous étiez attaché j'imagine pour
gagner la 11e circonscription des
Français de l'étranger où vous a succédé
notre code ange
ont été marqués par une activité
internationale intense principalement en
direction de la Russie des pays de
l'ex-URSS et du Moyen-Orient cette
activité s'est inscrite dans le cadre
des groupes d'amitié ou de la commission
des affaires étrangères
mais vous avez également effectué de
nombreux déplacements à votre initiative
ou à l'invitation des différents pays
que l'on pourrait qualifier de pro
démocratique je pense en particulier vos
visites en Syrie auprès de Bachar
el-Assad en Russie ou au Kazakhstan ou
encore en Crimée et dans le Dombasle
je précise par ailleurs que vous êtes
visé par deux enquêtes judiciaires en
lien avec l'association dialogue Franco
russe que vous présidez depuis 2012
ces enquêtes portent sur du trafic
d'influence et de la corruption ainsi
qu'un abus de confiance et blanchiment
d'argent d'autre part
bien évidemment il n'appartient pas à
notre commission de se prononcer sur
l'objet de ces enquêtes et sur une
éventuelle qualification pénale nous
souhaitons avant tout recueillir votre
témoignage sur vos relations avec
différents régimes étrangers pour la
plupart hostile à la France et dont il
est établi pour certains d'entre eux qui
mènent des actions d'ingérence dans les
affaires de notre pays
cette audition je le précise est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et
l'enregistrement vidéo sera ensuite
disponible à la demande
je vous laisserai la parole pour une
intervention luminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes puis nous poursuivrons nos
échanges sous la forme de question et de
réponse
auparavant je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre
1958 relatives au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vous invite donc à
lever la main droite et à dire je jure
je vous remercie vous avez la parole
je disais merci monsieur le Président
merci Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés je vous remercie
de m'avoir convoqué j'avais demandé
auprès de votre président effectivement
est traditionné par cette commission
surtout en ma qualité de président du
dialogue franco-russe qui alimente un
peu tous les fantasmes des uns ou des
autres sur les relations ou les moyens
dont on disposerait mais bien sûr je
répondrai à la totalité des questions
que vous souhaitez simplement mon
exposer les mineurs se limitera à au
dialogue franc-corus qu'est-ce que c'est
que et puis et puis sous forme je dis
avec un clin d'oeil je vous remercie de
m'avoir convoqué le 28 mars puisqu'il y
a exactement 30 ans le 28 mars 93
j'étais élu député voilà
cette séquence souvenir mise à part
qu'est-ce que c'est que le dialogue
franco-russe parce que quand je lis un
certain nombre de spécialistes j'ai vu
d'ailleurs que vous allez un auditionner
un ou deux j'ai quand même l'impression
que on est loin de la réalité
ou plutôt que la fiction dépasse très
largement la réalité le dialogue
franc-corrige me le permet de le
rappeler elle a été créée en 2004
par Jacques Chirac et Vladimir Poutine
et
ce dialogue franco-rus avait pour
vocation à l'origine de favoriser les
échanges économiques et politiques avec
la Russie il a fonctionné j'y reviendrai
tout à l'heure je pense dans les
questions il a fonctionné un plein
régime jusqu'en 2014 en 2014 il a eu un
premier coup d'arrêt parce que 2014 vous
le savez c'est la première vague de
sanction suite au rattachement de
l'Ukraine à la Russie et
avec une très forte raréfaction des
cotisations françaises
2021 c'est donc les événements qu'on
connaît avec la guerre entre l'Ukraine
et la Russie et donc là aussi nous avons
eu un deuxième j'allais dire une
deuxième vague qui fait que désormais
l'activité de notre association se
limite quasiment à des rencontres avec
des spécialistes qui sont retransmis sur
la chaîne Youtube pour la petite
histoire mon prédécesseur c'était alors
le dialogue francorus est présidé par un
co-président russe et un co-président
français
le premier président français et russe
c'était monsieur Hara je veux pas
déformer son nom haras abramian voilà
qui est en russe d'origine arménienne et
Monsieur Thierry Desmarais à l'époque
présidente ou directeur général chez
plus le titre exact enfin numéro 1 de
Total
et donc j'ai pris la suite de Thierry
Desmarais en 2004 en 2000 parlant pas 4
Quand Thierry Demaret a souhaité
démissionner à cette époque là aussi il
y a eu un changement de président ce
côté russe c'est Monsieur Vladimir
Yakounine qui a pris la présidence de
cette
association pourquoi à l'époque j'avais
été pressenti pour présider cette
association d'abord bien sûr pour mes
liens avec la Russie mais aussi parce
que le président côté russe Vladimir
Yakounine étant président de RGD RGD
c'est l'équivalent de la SNCF en gros la
première entreprise ferroviaire en 2019
j'ai retrouvé 711
000 employés il suffit de voir la
superficie de la Russie pour comprendre
et donc comme j'étais ancien ministre
des Transports et qui avait un certain
nombre de de j'allais dire d'intérêt
entre des entreprises
et entreprise russe en matière de
transport j'avais été pressenti à
l'époque pour pour prendre la présidence
de cette association donc j'assure la
présidence de cette association depuis
2012 j'ai je tiens à votre disposition
bien sûr tous les chiffres alors je dis
tout de suite je tiens à votre
disposition tous les chiffres qui me
restent en main puisque nous avons eu
une perquisition de la brigade
financière le 23 mars 2022 donc il y a
quasiment un an où je n'ai aucune
nouvelle et pour le moment les documents
nous ont toujours pas été rendus je
précise que la perquisition de la
brigade financière était pas faite pour
me viser ni pour viser le dialogue
franco-russe mais pour viser un ancien
directeur
soupçonné de certaines choses qui a
quitté le dialogue franco-russe il y a
trois ou quatre ans voilà et donc
aujourd'hui si vous voulez qu'est-ce que
c'est concrètement le dialogue
franco-rus c'est si je prends le budget
de l'année dernière c'est un budget de
86000 euros c'est à dire ne connaît pas
du tout dans les millions du Kremlin qui
déboulerait aujourd'hui en effet les
cotisants russes et bien tout simplement
ne peuvent plus participer pour des
raisons bancaires de sanctions voilà on
arrive encore à recevoir quelques
cotisations de particuliers mais qui
sont extrêmement réduites et d'autre
part ce qui est totalement nouveau on a
énormément de donateurs français de
petits donateurs français
puisque suite aux vidéos ça nous ramène
un certain nombre de donations qui sont
depuis le début qui sont par exemple
l'année dernière qui était de 17000
euros et en 2023 on est aussi à 17000
euros mais que pour trois mois voilà
est-ce que j'étais salarié par cette
association la réponse c'est non bien
sûr est-ce que j'ai été défrayé je fais
sortir par le commissaire aux comptes
depuis
12 j'ai touché 2126 euros de
remboursement en 12 ans ce qui fait une
moyenne 263 euros par mois de
remboursement de frais divers voilà pour
les différents chiffres au départ je
reviens sur ce que je disais pour que
vous compreniez bien au départ on était
dans une participation équilibrée entre
les entreprises russes et les
entreprises françaises 2014 a mis un
coup d'arrêt mais voyez par exemple les
entreprises françaises qui ont cotisé en
principalement jusqu'en 2014 je vous en
cite quelques-unes Alstom 50 000
Bouygues 8000 EADS
8000 yesmars c'est des ferroviaire 4000
jefco c'est du transport 8000
safran 8000 Sanofi Société Générale SNCF
Thalès total bref j'ai numère ces
sociétés pour dire que
jusqu'en 2014 c'était une
c'était une association qui organisait
en réalité quoi qui organisait des
contacts notre siège était au 2120
avenue des Champs-Élysées ou en partager
un plateau c'est à dire un étage avec
RZD les chemins de fer russe et ce qui
nous permettait d'organiser un certain
nombre de rencontres principalement soit
chaque fois qui avait des des
entrepreneurs qui souhaitaient des
contacts avec des entreprises russes
soient plus souvent quand des élus
locaux russes gouverneurs de région mers
etc passé et essayer de d'avoir des
contacts avec des élus locaux français
ou des responsables d'autorités locales
français voilà quel était notre notre
mission la dernier grand coloc que nous
avons organisé c'était en 2013 donc
juste avant la première vague de
sanctions c'était un grand coloc avec le
Medef français et bien sûr le Medef
russe à Paris
voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur cette
association vous avez fait part dans
votre introduction que j'étais sous
enquête depuis mars 2022 depuis avril
2021 c'est ça je pense que c'est le pur
coïncidence c'était juste un mois avant
les élections régionales ou certains me
voyaient gagner mais je suis persuadé
que c'est une coïncidence et depuis mars
2021 je n'ai jamais vu un policier
jamais vu un magistrat et telle sera
j'attends d'être enfin convoquée voilà
je précise je le renouvelle devant cette
commission je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises devant les des caméras puisqu’à
chaque fois les médias me font la bonté
de me le rappeler à chaque intervention
je précise que si je suis convoqué par
un juge j'ai accouré
et que c'est pas la peine de demander
quel que soit mon immunité parlementaire
voilà j'ai pas de je n'ai rien à cacher
sur cette association je présume
d'ailleurs que si la brigade financière
qui a emporté toute une série d'archives
depuis cette époque et qui ne s'est pas
manifester depuis un an je pense que
elle fait le même constat que ce que je
suis en train de vous dire voilà après
pour
c'était surtout ce dialogue franco-russe
que je voulais intervenir mais bien sûr
je répondrai à toutes vos questions je
vais pas dire un mot combien de temps il
me reste
un mot si vous voulez sur sur le
document 6 minutes sur sur le reste
j'ai fait des études de droit
international donc je m'intéresse à
l'international voilà je précise en plus
que j'étais j'ai passé mon bac dans une
école militaire et qu'à l'époque on nous
poussait à prendre le russe pour
préparer la guerre d'après voilà donc
contrairement à toutes les légendes
romantiques que j'entends je me suis pas
intéressé à la Russie parce que ma
seconde épouse était russe la première
était savoyarde mais tout simplement
parce que quand je suis arrivé il y a 30
ans dans cette assemblée on n'était pas
beaucoup à plus ou moins par les Russes
je dis plus ou moins parce que
dans les députés que j'ai connu il y en
avait un qui parlait en russe absolument
parfait qui était Mariton
et d'autres qui parlaient le Russe pas
parfait surtout avec les déclinaisons
dans moi-même mais ça nous a permis en
tout cas un d'être assez d'être
forcément
intéressé au moment où en décembre de
1991 je vous rappelle l'Union soviétique
s'effondre c'est 15 nouveaux États et 15
nouveaux États qui construisent des
relations diplomatiques avec la France
qui cherchent des contacts la France
aussi envoie des délégations
parlementaires et forcément quand je me
suis intéressé à ces zones là si vous
regardez mon parcours politique à
l'Assemblée j'ai présidé cinq groupes
j'ai fait cinq mandats
vous l'avez dit l'avant-dernière complet
puisque j'étais ministre au milieu mon
premier mandat à l'époque la majorité
avait 450 députés on est bien loin de
aujourd'hui 450 députés
RPR et UDF et donc j'avais demandé la
présidence d'un groupe d'amitié donc on
m'a dit très gentiment que si je
survivais au second on m'en donnerai un
deuxième mandat c'est une majorité
Jospin 97 2002 j'avais demandé la
présidence d'un groupe d'amitié d'Europe
de l'Est on m'a donné le cire Leon qui
comme chacun le sait est en Afrique et à
l'époque en plus c'était en pleine
guerre civile donc j'ai passé mon temps
à donner des réserves parlementaires à
des ONG
qui c'était une guerre assez horrible
lui couper les membres qui qui faisait
des prothèses mon troisième mandat
contrairement à ce que certains écrivent
je n'ai jamais présidé le groupe
d'amitié France Russie à mon grand
regret mon troisième mandat j'ai présidé
le groupe d'amitié France Ukraine
ce qui m'a valu de connaître aussi un
peu ce pays quatrième mandat j'ai
présidé France Kazakhstan enfin France
Azerbaïdjan puis entre temps je suis
devenu quatrième ou cinquième je me
souviens plus enfin bref Azerbaïdjan et
Kazakhstan voilà donc effectivement je
connais un peu cette zone d'Asie
centrale parce que comme d'autres
spécialiste sur l'Afrique je me suis
spécialisé un peu sur cette zone parce
que je l'ai connu j'ai eu la chance de
la connaître j'allais dire qu'en 1991
tout s'était fondé voir ses États se
constituer voir un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques prendre de
l'importance et j'ai gardé et je ne le
renie pas un certain loyer la semaine
prochaine je repars en Ouzbékistan en
voyage avec l'Assemblée nationale je
j'ai gardé un certain nombre de
relations dans ces pays
et avec le Parlement européen pardon
j'ai dit l'Assemblée nationale pardon
excuse-moi excusez-moi j'ai dit 25 ans
pardon avec le Parlement européen
voilà et donc au Parlement européen bien
sûr je suis à la commission des affaires
étrangères comme je le fus lors de mon
dernier mandat ici et quand on me
reproche aussi certaines relations en
Asie Pacifique ou dans une partie de
l'Europe de l'Est c'est pas Madame gente
qui me démentira quand vous êtes député
le 11e circonscription forcément il y en
a une partie qui est c'est pas une
partie c'est la totalité qui est dans
cette zone voilà donc ce qui me
permettait aussi à l'époque de faire un
certain nombre de voyages etc voilà je
suis à votre disposition j'ai pas
utilisé les 15 minutes mais pour
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
souhaiteriez
merci chers collègues moi j'avais deux
questions pour lancer un petit peu le
débat nouveau en tout cas les questions
réponses
alors que vous avez fait qui est un lien
avec ce que vous venez de dire juste
avant que j'avais fait toutes d'autres
carrière politique dans le Vaucluse je
crois qu'est-ce qui vous décide en 2012
vous présenter une élection pour les
Français de l'étranger dans une zone à
laquelle vous n'habitez pas
c'est une bonne question vous savez j'ai
eu la chance d'être trois fois mère
trois fois conseillé général quatre fois
quand c'est régional
j'ai été maire et député de là où je
suis né là où mes parents sont mon père
est enterré là où mes grands-parents
sont enterrés j'ai été très fiers d'être
mère et conseiller général et député
pendant 20 ans de cet endroit-là je vous
le souhaite de l'être mais au bout de 20
ans vous avez envie de faire un peu
autre chose voilà c'est tout je vous dis
la vérité en plus pourquoi à l'époque
j'étais responsable de des Français de
l'étranger au archipacité le rprump ou
peut-être les républicains même bref
j'étais c'est la même formation on va
pas jouer sur les mots j'étais
responsable des Français de l'étranger
depuis des années j'avais organisé
d'ailleurs la représentation de la
formation de droite dans cette zone et
quand Nicolas Sarkozy a décidé pendant
son premier mandat de créer des
circonscriptions des Français de
l'étranger j'avais dit clairement que je
souhaitais peut-être arrêter la
politique mais qu'une circonscription
des Français de m'intéresser voilà et
donc qui m'a proposé cette
circonscription des Français de
l'étranger qui pour moi était celle qui
m'intéressait le plus alors pour
répondre à vos questions j'y habitais
pas vous avez raison
mais mettons occupé des problèmes des
Français de l'étranger pendant des
années au sein du parti j'avais quelques
connaissances là-dessus voilà et donc
j'ai pas quitté je précise que j'ai fait
trois mandats de mer ville repris à la
gauche et que je n'ai jamais perdu je
crois que ma dernière élection c'est 70%
map
idem au conseil général et ma dernière
élection de député dans le Vaucluse
c'est 60%. donc c'est tout simplement
que j'aurai envie de faire autre chose
voilà il y a des gens qui ont la
mentalité de notable et je trouve ça
très respectable on parlait tout à
l'heure de nos collègues cette illustrés
dans de vos collègues aujourd'hui pardon
excusez-moi d'un de vos collègues qui
s'est illustré par une motion de censure
moi j'admire les gens qui ont leur
septième au 8e mandat j'ai pas la
mentalité de notable je préfère faire un
peu tourner un peu voilà et donc
aujourd'hui je suis très content d'être
député européen et voilà pourquoi je
m'étais présenté aux Français de
l'étranger
merci j'avais une deuxième question à me
laisser la parole même la rapporteur
c'est un peu plus technique mais en 2020
vous participez avec une dizaine d'euros
députés de votre partie un référendum
constitutionnel organisé par Vladimir
Poutine en Russie un référendum qui est
notamment à inscrire dans la
Constitution l'interdiction des mariages
homosexuels lui permettent de rester au
pouvoir en nombre illimité demandant à
cette occasion vous n'avez vous avez
indiqué d'avoir remarqué aucune entorse
électorales contrairement d'autres
observateurs qui ont remarqué que des
bureaux de vote étaient installés à
l'arrière de SUV il y a des vidéos qui
ont circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
que les journalistes sur place notamment
l'agence associée à société de presse
a remarqué que il y avait des remises de
prix pour ceux qui voulaient voter le
oui est-ce que vous pensez que le fait
que votre voyage dans un hôtel luxueux à
cette époque payé par la Fédération de
Russie
puisse altérer ou semble altérer votre
jugement
je recherche dans ma tête
excuse-moi une seconde une page vous
recherchez
en 2020 c'était un référendum si ma
mémoire est bonne où il y avait une
centaine d'articles une centaine
d'articles
le principaux vous l'avez dit c'était
surtout la prolongation du mandat du
Président de la République et d'autre
part c'était une manière implicite
soyons clairs de reconnaître le
rattachement de la Crimée à la Russie
voilà je vous rappelle que si vous avez
la curiosité de regarder il y avait même
un article sur le statut des animaux
pour vous dire que c'était 36 j'avoue
honnêtement avoir oublié qu'il y avait
quelque chose éventuellement sur le
mariage homosexuel la question centrale
c'était est-ce que l'Ukraine est-ce que
pardon la Crimée et russe ou pas est-ce
que j'ai participé bien sûr je veux dire
nous avons même été sanctionné sur
aucune base juridique au Parlement
européen
je dis bien aucune base juridique
puisque la sanction au Parlement
européen s'applique sur un article qui
est pour les députés en mission
officielle par définition puisque je
n'étais pas en mission officielle je
vois mal comment on peut m'appliquer une
sanction qui concerne la démission qui
ne sont pas officielles voilà est-ce que
pour moi l'élection s'est passée
correctement il y a des centaines de
bureau de vote ce qu'on a vu et on les
avait choisis se sont passés
correctement est-ce que il y avait ce
que vous dites des bureaux de vote à
l'arrière de véhicule et tout c'est fort
possible je vais vous dire probable
voilà après vous savez pendant mes 25
ans 23 ans à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
siégé à l'OSCE pendant trois mandats si
mymore est bonne et au camp et à
l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'OSCE
pendant trois mandats et à l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe
pendant deux mandat c'est-à-dire j'ai dû
faire à peu près une soixantaine de
missions officielles d'observation dans
des organismes bien j'allais dire
reconnu l'expérience me montre que les
règles d'observation sont par moments
très souples voilà dans certains pays si
on observateur étranger se fait sortir
d'un bureau de vote en nous expliquera
que c'est une atteinte à l'élection si
aux États-Unis on se fait sortir d'un
bureau de vote comme ce fut le cas avec
Monsieur Michel Voisin dans un bureau de
vote dans le Colorado parce qu'ils
acceptent pas les observateurs étrangers
tout le monde trouve ça normal voilà je
me souviens aussi d'élection
en Irak ou en Afghanistan ou on ne
connaissait pas les résultats ni les
bureaux de vote pour des raisons de
sécurité 48 heures avant et où l'OSCE a
validé quand même les élections donc ce
que je veux dire par là et je l'ai dit
publiquement c'est validations
d'élections par organisme de l'OSCE ou
plutôt du bébé DH très souvent sont
quand même à mon avis ouvertement
merci c'est votre point de vue je vais
laisser la parole à Constance
sur l'hôtel pardon non entre temps on a
fait passer l'hôtel de luxe et le
Radisson à Moscou quoi qui arrive qui
est un bon hôtel mais enfin c'est pas
l'hôtel de luxe voilà et puis et puis si
vous permettez parce qu'il y a toute une
mythologie sur les voyages
les voyages à mon avis c'est quand même
quand est-ce que pour moi ils sont
condamnables si on reste 10 jours après
au bord de la plage si après on fait du
tourisme vous me ferez grâce que tous
les voyages que j'ai déclaré que ce soit
au Parlement européen ou que ce soit à
l'Assemblée nationale quand la
réglementation est intervenue puisque je
crois qu'il y a une réglementation sur
les
on a créé le déontologue je crois que
c'était Bernard collier qui avait créé
déontologue à chaque fois tout a été
déclaré voilà tout a été déclaré et à
chaque fois je précise
c'est on n'a pas fait du tout de
tourisme voilà c'est uniquement des
déplacements politiques si on veut aussi
connaître un peu l'international je
pense que par moment il faut aussi se
rendre sur place
très bien
merci monsieur le Président alors je
veux juste en préambule rappeler ça a
été dit par le président mais que
l'association dialogue franco-russe est
visé par deux enquêtes deux enquêtes
préliminaires des soupçons de corruption
et trafic d'influence d'un côté abus de
confiance et blanchiment de l'autre ne
l'obstant ces procédures en cours nous
avons souhaité vous entendre et nous
avons d'ailleurs écouté très
attentivement ce que vous nous avez dit
sur l'association dialogue franco-rus et
il appartiendra à la justice le cas
échéant de trancher mais je voulais
également
dire un peu la raison pour laquelle
nous vous avons convoqué parce que
incontestablement votre déjà long
parcours politique et professionnel
vous amène à être un objet je dirais de
curiosité et attention et d'intérêt
soutenu pour une commission d'enquête
comme la nôtre dont l'objet et d'être
dédié aux risques aux menaces
d'ingérence étrangère dans le débat
politique français dans les relais
d'opinion médias parti politique alors
ingérence étrangère influence
interférence la sémantique et est variée
mais elle amène toujours à s'intéresser
de près je dirais à vos activités vos
responsabilités vos choix et vos votes
et vos votes par exemple récents au
Parlement
européen alors pour en venir à mes
questions
et on aura l'occasion peut-être
d'avoir des questions qui touchent à
d'autres zones je souhaite quand même
revenir sur
dialogue franco-russe pour que soit
précisé deux trois petites choses aux
membres de la commission d'enquête
vous avez dit que les locaux à un moment
donné que vous partagiez des locaux
avenue des Champs-Élysées avec
la société ferroviaire russe rzhd que
vous partagez voilà parlons que vous
partagiez un plateau est-ce que vous
payez un loyer ou un sous loyer est-ce
que c'est locaux étaient prêtés par la
société
ferroviaire
russe
est-ce que
les travaux que vous avez
eu à conduire avec le co-président qui
était à vos côtés le coach président
russe Vladimir Yakounine
vous ont conduit à aller au-delà
des activités de l'association elle-même
telle qu'elles sont listées par voilà ce
qu'on peut trouver comme brochure de
présentation officielle de l'association
qu'elles étaient il y avait-il d'autres
intérêts aviez-vous d'autres liens avec
Monsieur iaconin que ceux d'être
co-président à ses côtés à la tête de
dialogue
franco-rus voilà ça c'était les deux
premières questions et j'en ai d'autres
après
alors pour répondre précisément avec
deux premières questions le siège quand
Vladimir yakoni est arrivé il a déménagé
donc c'était avant que je sois président
avant le siège du dialogue franco-rus
c'était rue Pierre 1er de Serbie donc
quelque chose on va dire de d'assez
modeste
à ce moment-là il est donc je vous
rappelle il est donc président de
l'équivalent de la SNCF russe on est la
France est en négociation pour notamment
une ligne à grande vitesse pour du
matériel ferroviaire etc et forcément
ils ont des moyens relativement
importants et ils décident de
déménager au 120 avenue des
Champs-Élysées c'est là où je dis en
loue un plateau c'est à dire un étage
qui le loup officiellement qui le loue
c'est nous à savoir le dialogue
franco-rus le loyer de mémoire et de 220
ou de 240 000 euros par an
c'était d'ailleurs l'essentiel des
dépenses 2 et il nous en rembourse la
moitié c'est à dire en réalité
en gros je cherche les chiffres mais je
suis pas bon comptable c'est chaque
année nous rembourser 120000 ou 110 000
euros de loyer tout simplement pourquoi
parce que
il y a en partager en réalité les salles
de réunion et je le répète ils
occupaient la moitié du plateau
donc ça c'était la première question la
deuxième que vous m'avez posée c'est
est-ce que mes relations avec Yakounine
sont allés plus loin que des relations
de co-présidence oui je vais vous dire
ça allait ça a été les relations
d'amitié de sympathie c'est un
personnage mais je n'ai jamais fait
d'affaires avec lui si vous regardez
notamment Monsieur Benoît vitekin
puisque tout un tas de légendes
circulent a fait une un certain nombre
d'enquêtes sur moi etc et à chaque fois
on remarque que il n'y a strictement
rien à part un article de qui évoque une
société qui s'appelle CFG capital
qui gèrerait deux milliards d'euros
c'est FG capital qui n'a jamais existé
puisqu'en réalité c'était une personne
qui avait annoncé mon nom comme
conseiller dans cette société pour lever
des fonds et que cette société n'a
jamais existé 2 milliards ça se remarque
si cette société existait depuis 2014
voilà donc pour répondre très clairement
non je n'ai jamais fait d'affaires avec
eux et je précise d'autre part non je
n'ai jamais fait d'affaires en général
quand j'ai été battu en 2017 j'ai vendu
la maison de mon père à Valréas vous me
posiez la question tout simplement pour
continuer parce que j'ai une famille etc
si j'avais fait des affaires ailleurs je
serais parti ailleurs
voilà contrairement à d'autres j'ai
jamais été conseillé salarié dans une
entreprise j'ai jamais pris de
commission dans une entreprise russe ce
qui me permet aujourd'hui d'être très à
l'aise et vous avez fait référence
effectivement à cette enquête depuis
deux ans je le répète deux ans
vous en êtes vous avec
c'est absolument pas ironique mais votre
intervention est l'illustration de
l'utilisation de sorte de cette sorte
d'enquête c'est que ça permet à chaque
fois un journaliste de avant de prendre
la parole de jeter le discrédit oui il y
a une enquête qui est ouverte depuis
deux ans franchement quand vous verrez
les chiffres du dialogue franco-rus s'il
faut deux ans pour examiner ça
il y a un problème voilà je vous précise
aussi que étant je suis soumis à toute
une série de contrôles comme vous par la
Haute Autorité ou je ne sais que tout ce
que vous connaissez en tant que député
européen je vous précise que quand j'ai
été ministre des Transports vous en
doutez il y a eu quand même une certaine
enquête sur je vous précise que vous les
en vous en souvenir qu'avant d'être
ministre des Transports j'étais au
représentant de la France nommée par
Nicolas Sarkozy en succession de Pierre
Lelouch un Afghanistan travaillant avec
l'OTAN travaillant avec l'OTAN à Kaboul
là aussi vous doutez qu'il y a quand
même eu une certaine enquête sur moi
donc je sais que
ingérence influence j'ai vu un grand
article de presse au moment des
régionales où j'étais un homme
d'influence ou sous-influence
ça alimente toutes les légendes que vous
voulez mais
je pense que si j'allais toucher quelque
chose du gouvernement russe ou d'une
entreprise russe on ne serait depuis
longtemps
ah pardon
merci je poursuis dans un livre qui a
fait un petit peu de bruit lorsqu'il est
sorti alors également il date un peu
2016 la France russe le journaliste
Nicolas Henin parlant de dialogue
franco-russe dit que cette session est
une structure rejoint les guillemets
vérolées par le SVR le service des
renseignements extérieurs russes que
répondez-vous à cette assertion
excusez-moi je vais m'y faire que
Nicolas Henin dans chacun de nous
connaît les idées défend plus ses idées
mais n'apporte aucun élément voilà je
suis désolé le SVR
[Musique]
franchement
en quoi en quoi aujourd'hui le SVR
réunit une influence là-dedans voilà
faut être sérieux vous savez c'est comme
quand on est accusé au Parlement
européen d'avoir de filer des secrets
aux Russes si vous pouvez me dire quel
est le secret que détient un député du
Parlement européen d'opposition vous
m'intéressez parce que à part la salle
de réunion de la prochaine commission je
vois pas tellement quel secret est à ma
disposition voilà le SVR non excuse-moi
je suis désolé il n'est pas je vois pas
pourquoi il serait verroulé par le SVR
alors je vois peut-être que je me
souviens plus il y a tellement eu de
bouquins écrits sur nous on devient on
devrait toucher des commissions demander
des cotisations plutôt sur les livres
parce que
le président le président ou le
responsable du SVR actuel et Monsieur
Vladimir Yakounine non pas Vladimir
Yakounine pardon Aristide nachkine qui
fut décoré la Légion d'honneur française
qui parle français comme vous et moi qui
a été président de la Douma qui est venu
dans ses murs d'ailleurs à une époque
voilà donc je connais monsieur nariskin
mais je les connais j'ai connu monsieur
Narry skin en tant que président de
l'Assemblée nationale
et en tant que francophone et
francophile voilà je ne le connais pas
en tant que responsable des services
secrets russes voilà et puis et puis je
crois qu'il faut si vous me permettez il
faut un peu arrêter les fantasmes vous
êtes député j'ai un profond respect
c'est pas du tout ce que je veux dire
c'est pas une critique attention je l'ai
été 25 ans je suis député européen à
part ceux qui sont dans des commissions
très spéciales sur leur enseignement ou
sur d'autres quel est le secret qu'on
détient voilà si vous me le dites moi je
suis intéressé il y a des je pense qu'il
y a encore toujours une commission sur
leur enseignement il doit toujours
merci merci madame le rapporteur voilà
oui ces personnes là tienne ont accès à
des secrets mais ça fait un nombre assez
restreint sur les 577 parlementaires
voilà sur les 750 députés européens je
vous rassure s'il y avait des secrets on
serait certainement les derniers à nous
le dire mais il y en a pas voilà donc il
faut aussi arrêter de fantasmer et si
vous me permettez de sortir un peu des
limites de votre question je crois que
les influences il faut peut-être les
chercher ailleurs qu'en politique je
citerai pas de nom mais quand je vois
par exemple un ancien secrétaire général
du Quai d'Orsay qui a été l'un des
principaux responsables du Quai d'Orsay
pendant des années passées après au
service de Blackstone société de fusion
acquisition fusion américaine
est-ce qu'il est pas est-ce qu'il
connaît pas bien plus de secrets que
n'importe lequel des députés dans cette
salle quand je vois un ancien chef
d'état-major de la
Défense de l'armée
dont on a beaucoup parlé le général De
Villiers qui passe
au service d'une société américaine BCG
pareil est-ce qu'il ne connaît pas bien
plus de secret que tout ça donc il faut
je sais bien qu'on fait une fixation sur
les députés mais la vraie question à
vous poser c'est qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
Secret voilà j'ai eu quelques secrets
madame le grip effectivement quand
j'étais en Afghanistan je le reconnais
après même ministre des Transports
je cherche désespérément qu'il se crée a
été en ma position à ma possession
[Musique]
par l'affirmative mais enfin voilà c'est
une simple supputation de ma part à ce
stade mais j'ai une question très
précise concernant une personnalité
proche du régime du président Poutine je
pense à l'oligarque Constantin mal au VF
que vous avez rencontré je pense que ça
pour le coup c'est documenter et comme
vous avez dû rencontrer beaucoup
d'autres personnalités oligarques ou
proches du régime en place donc vous
avez rencontré
à au moins une reprise à Moscou en 2014
l'oligarque Constantin manoeuf bon ok je
crois rentrer d'ailleurs dans la liste
des donateurs de dialogues franco-rus
après ce rendez-vous mais c'est pas
tellement cela qui qui m'intéresse je
crois qu'il vous avait proposé ou
peut-être espacées par un intermédiaire
à un moment donné même si ce n'est pas
fait d'intégrer le comité consultatif
d'un fond d'investissement Franco
franco-russe mais mais ça ne s'est ça ne
s'est pas fait manifestement puisqu'on
parle de ce dont la presse française a
eu l'occasion
d'évoquer certaines activités est-ce que
vous avez eu à connaître ou est-ce que
vous avez peut-être même été amenés à
participer aux réflexions réunions de
travail sur le projet alt interne un
projet porté par monsieur malov qui est
alt interne qui est un projet dont la
presse française et la presse européenne
c'est assez abondamment fait l'écho qui
est un projet
de rassemblement et d'alliance de toutes
les extrêmes droites européennes
favorables à Vladimir Poutine et sur
lequel monsieur a travaillé d'ailleurs
il a eu l'occasion de son entretenir à
plusieurs reprises par exemple avec l'un
de vos collègues également membre du
rasement national Monsieur Philippe
Olivier voilà ce projet a connu
évidemment après l'invasion russe de
l'Ukraine quelques moments de mise en
mise en sommeil si je puis dire mais ne
serait pas totalement
abandonné voilà donc ça c'était l'une de
mes questions
pardon
est-ce que j'ai gardé des contacts avec
les responsables politiques russes
malheureusement je veux dire j'ai passé
des années là-bas
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a plus que
jamais besoin d'avoir des contacts avec
la Russie faudra bien le jour un jour
l'autre faire la paix avec qui
principalement c'est pas le secret de
toute façon j'ai gardé les contacts par
exemple avec celui qui a présidé le
groupe d'amitié France Russie à la Douma
monsieur léonitz lutzky que j'ai connu
jeune député qui aujourd'hui est
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et qui est venu dans ces
bâtiments X fois et qui était là aussi
l'entre parenthèses décorer les gens
d'honneur et qui est francophone voilà
je sais pas si d'ailleurs il préside
toujours le groupe je sais pas bon de
toute façon je pense qu'il se réunit
plus beaucoup je connais très bien
que ce soit aussi maintenant le voit un
peu à la télé Tolstoï pierre Tolstoï qui
est le premier vice-président de la
Douma qui comme vous l'avez pu le
constater et francophone
petit couramment et je vais pas vous
énumérer le nombre de députés que j'ai
connus ou que je connais
j'ai pas cité le nouveau président du
dialogue franco-russe monsieur catasonov
mais par exemple qui a été lui aussi
député puisque Vladimir il y a connu n'a
arrêté il y a deux ou trois ans à peu
près donc oui j'en connais mais bon
c'est logique je vais en Russie depuis
30 ans donc heureusement que j'ai gardé
des relations avec eux est-ce que je
est-ce que j'ai vu ma Constantin Malo
feuillete oui bien sûr j'ai vu c'est pas
un oligarque parmi les plus riches de
Russie mais c'est vrai que c'est un
oligarque qui intéresse la presse parce
que il a contrairement à d'autres un
vrai rôle politique voilà et qu'il était
assez engagé sur certains sujets
franchement je connais pas le progrès
alors laissez-moi aller jusqu'au bout je
connais pas le programme al interne
oui j'ai participé à une réunion avec
Monsieur maloufef dans l'école j'ai vu
monsieur voilà est-ce que j'ai participé
à une réunion avec lui oui réponse bien
sûr
il avait fait une réunion je peux vous
dire très précisément quand au moment de
la coupe du monde de football voilà et
donc pour la petite histoire je n'étais
plus ni député européen ni député
français j'étais simple citoyen voilà
donc j'ai pas encore l'obligation de
déclarer mes voyages en 2018 puisque
j'étais je le répète plus rien sans
projet c'était plus là aussi je sais que
ça fait fantasmer tout un tas de
journalistes son projet c'était plus des
échanges avec un certain nombre de
responsables on va dire de
différents pays qui n'étaient pas
forcément alignés sur l'OTAN voilà bien
plus que pro Poutine ou voilà donc
est-ce que alors et ensuite vous avez
posé la question sur CFG capital puisque
c'est un peu ce que j'avais anticipé oui
puisque c'est chaque fois l'article
qu'on me ressort à un moment alors lui
il m'a certifié qu'il était même pas
dans l'affaire mais à un moment une
personne vous trouverez le nom je crois
qu'il savait je me suis
pierre l'ouvrier j'ai jamais su la
vérité complètement pierre Louvrier qui
est un Français expatrié avait décidé de
d'essayer de créer ce fond je le répète
de 2 milliards et m'avait demandé si
éventuellement chez j'aurais été prêt à
être
conseiller dans ce dans ce fond non
rémunéré ou rémunérés ça n'avait pas été
défini puisque j'attendais que ce fond
soit créé se font et il disait à la dans
le communiqué qui a été passé à la
presse il disait que c'était en lien
avec Constantin malofeiev voilà est-ce
que c'était vrai est-ce que c'était faux
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que le
fond n'a jamais existé voilà donc je
n'ai un ce fond de monsieur malof n'a
jamais existé de forcément comme il n'a
jamais existé j'étais jamais
administrateur et puis je répète comme
je fais l'objet de toute l'attention de
la presse et je n'en remercie en
permanence vous doutez que si j'étais
administrateur d'un fond de 2 milliards
ça serait
oui dans les personnalités pardon
politique excusez-moi c'est vrai que on
me souffle que je j'ai beaucoup de
relations effectivement avec la Crimée
je vais vous dire pourquoi j'ai été
président de France Ukraine c'est-à-dire
que je fais partie de ceux qui ont dû
aller une dizaine de fois en criée
ukrainienne crimérus avant et après 2014
et donc
j'y suis allé d'abord parce que quand à
l'époque on est président de France
Ukraine les députés Ukrainiens une fois
qu'ils vous ont montré qui elles veulent
vous montrer un peu la Crimée
aujourd'hui j'ai vu la je dois être l'un
des rares à pouvoir dire que j'ai vu la
Crimée du temps de l'Ukraine où il y
avait complètement aucun investissement
qui était fait qui tombait j'allais dire
qui était un territoire un peu qui
n'intéressait visiblement pas le pays et
la Crimée depuis 2014 voilà et donc je
vois aussi la différence de de la
population depuis qu'elle est devenue
qu'elle est qu'elle est à nouveau
devenue russe et c'est certainement une
des régions sur lesquelles à mon avis le
choix de la population est peu
discutable et puis enfin après on peut
dire Madame legrippe après on peut
discuter du droit tant que vous voulez
mais
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que sur le
référendum sur l'indépendance de
l'Ukraine qui a eu lieu à voir en
2016 après l'explosion de l'Union
soviétique donc ça devait être au début
des années 2000 la Crimée était le
territoire qui avait eu le plus petit
score pour l'indépendance de l'Ukraine
qui était le cinéma est bonne de 53%
mais c'est comment oui mais bien sûr ça
ferait ça ferait rêver certains
politiques français aujourd'hui 53 %
mais voilà et d'autre part pourquoi
j'allais aussi en Crimée parce que je
vous rappelle pour la petite histoire et
l'anecdote que c'est l'endroit où vous
avez le plus grand cimetière militaire
français à l'étranger puisque entre
1851 et 1856 si mémoire est bonne on a
eu la guerre de Crimée qu'on a à peu
près 90 000 soldats français enterré là
et c'était pour nous l'occasion à chaque
fois de voir comment ce cimetière était
entretenu après avoir été habilis
réhabilité grâce à d'ailleurs un
ambassadeur français qui était monsieur
de Surin
ez je reconnais le connaître mais je
pense qu'il y a tribu beaucoup de
qualités qui rêveraient mais qui dépasse
un peu à mon avis la réalité quant à ce
grand projet je l'ai lu dans les
bouquins de madame je savais pas que ça
peut aller de ce nom là mais j'ai lu les
certains articles de presse que ce soit
madame vessier que ce soit monsieur ena
je pense que tout ça était tout
simplement une réunion comme il en
existe de temps en temps dans toute une
série d'amicales internationales
oui une dernière question et après
c'est le président qui distribue la
parole normalement donc je laisse le
président décider
la parole d'une dernière fois pourquoi
pour dire qu'il n'a jamais cotisé au DFR
[Musique]
malof voilà c'est tout donc
alors il y a quelques jours le 23 mars
dernier vous y faisiez allusion tout à
l'heure le Parlement européen a fait
savoir en vous interdisant expressément
à vous à vos collègues Jeanlin La
Capelle et à hervé Juvin que vous
n'étiez plus en situation de pouvoir
mener ou participer à des missions
officielles d'observation des élections
à l'étranger alors j'ai entendu nous
avons tous entendu que vous contestiez
je dirais juridiquement le fait pour le
Parlement européen de de donner cette
interdit dans la mesure où vous estimez
que quand vous vous déplaciez en Russie
ou ou
en Crimée par exemple y compris depuis
l'annexion de la Crimée par par la
Russie vous n'y alliez pas en mission
officielle d'observation des élections
du Parlement européen mais à d'autres
d'autres titres néanmoins toujours en
tout cas très souvent en votre qualité
de demande du Parlement européen et
présenter d'ailleurs dans les médias
locaux russes la plupart du temps comme
membre du Parlement européen donc après
on peut sur les mots effectivement jouer
de mission officielle pas officielle
mais quand même en votre qualité de
député au Parlement européen et donc le
Parlement européen a décidé d'interdire
cela vous nous confirmez donc que les
différents déplacements que vous avez
fait vous en avez fait beaucoup pour des
missions d'observation électorale en
Russie ou encore en Crimée je reste sur
cette zone là on va parler du Kazakhstan
ou d'autres régions vous êtes également
déplacés pour des missions d'observation
pour
certaines d'entre elles ont été
financées par la Russie ou pas
d'autres entités
alors
depuis que je suis député européen je
suis allé deux fois dans des missions
d'observation en Russie et au Kazakhstan
c'est bien ça
et en Ouzbékistan
en Russie celle de 2020 elle a bien été
financée par la dotation c'est ça
je vais vous répondre avec quelques
attitudes
enfin bref il y a un des deux
déplacements qui a été je regarde
ça
en 2020 effectivement le déplacement est
à l'invitation des Russes et donc
et donc payé par les Russes ce que ce
qui est déclaré je précise que pour ceux
qui suivent l'actualité européenne suite
au scandale du cathargate pour la petite
histoire il y a aucun député du
rassemblement national qui est impliqué
le
journal Le Soir belge qui a regardé les
déclarations des différents députés sur
le site où normalement on doit les
déclarer nous a presque rendu hommage
puisqu'il a déclaré que c'est notre
groupe qui déclarait tout et un certain
nombre de parlementaires visiblement en
se sont souvenus trois quatre ans après
de leur déplacement qu'ils avaient
oublié de signaler j'ai vu par exemple
madame Loiseau était un Arménie en
voiture je la félicite elle avait oublié
de déclarer un an et demi avant la
déclaré un an et demi après voilà nous
on a toujours respecté donc oui en 2020
le déplacement a été effectivement payé
par les Russes on a déclaré je répète il
suffit de taper sur mon profil sur
Internet et la deuxième mission
en réalité a été remboursé par ma
dotation annuelle c'est-à-dire que je
crois que vous avez été député
européenne aussi voilà donc vous
connaissez cette honorable maison je le
dis pour mes collègues mes collègues
français qui n'ont enfin qui n'ont pas
eu
encore cette possibilité au Parlement
européen existe une enveloppe qui est de
4500 euros si ma mémoire est bonne
700 euros où vous pouvez aller pour un
voyage politique où vous voulez à
condition d'avoir une invitation donc le
paradoxe c'est qu'il y a au moins il y
avait une émission de télé qui était
complément d'enquête c'est ça qui avait
vérifié tous mes déplacements et qui
avait trouvé qu'il y avait un
déplacement qu'on avait oublié de
signaler on l'avait pas signalé parce
que tout simplement il était payé par le
Parlement européen avec cette fameuse
enveloppe que vous connaissez enveloppe
avec cette ligne de crédit à savoir que
le deuxième a été payé par le Parlement
européen donc le paradoxe
mais c'est très
établir dans la ça illustre à mon avis
tous les
ambiguïtés de Bruxelles c'est qu'en
réalité je suis condamné pour un
déplacement comme remboursé
avec le sourire je suis condamné pour un
déplacement quand nous a remboursé
puisque on respectait les règles
administratives de du
déplacement c'était sur une invitation
et par contre le déplacement était
politiquement est correct j'attire votre
attention sur les députés français des
députés français sur quand même quelque
chose que je trouve extrêmement choquant
au Parlement européen
dans ce Parlement je me souviens par
moment par exemple d'avoir eu monsieur
Fabius venir la commission des affaires
étrangères nous expliquer à Jacques
Miard ou à moi qu'on n'avait pas le
droit d'aller enfin qu'il ne voulait pas
qu'on aille en Crimée on y est quand
même aller on n'a jamais eu de sanction
parce que c'est la liberté des
parlementaires d'aller où vous voulez au
Parlement européen
si je comprends bien je n'ai pas le
droit d'aller dans certains pays sous
sinon je suis sanctionné voilà et je
trouve quand même que cela est quand
même un peu dangereux
oui en mission d'observation mais j'y
vais pas j'y vais pas attendez j'y vais
à chaque fois les déclarations étaient
très claires j'y vais à titre individuel
voilà j'y vais à titre individuel
très bien merci madame le rapporteur je
souhaitais vous poser encore deux
questions de passer la parole aux autres
commissaires
comme on l'a évoqué un petit peu au
début on va recevoir Monsieur clickman
la semaine prochaine qui est donc le
président de la commission spéciale du
Parlement européen
sur l'ingérance étrangère et donc en
tant que on peut vous considérer comme
un spécialiste de l'ingérance étrangère
puisque vous avez fait partie de cette
commission pendant je crois deux ans et
cette belle commission point de faire
responsabilité de la Russie et de la
Chine dans le diffusion de force des
informations et le rapport c'est la vie
de Commission fait allusion à 300
millions de dollars américains injectés
par la Russie la Chine et d'autres
régimes autoritaires dans 33 pays il y a
des fins d'ingérence je voulais savoir
s'il y a votre avis à votre connaissance
la France est concernée par ces
ingérences
alors pour pardon monsieur le Président
pour être tout à fait honnête je suis
j'ai été membre de cette commission il y
a eu on l'appelle ING au Parlement
européen influence étrangère je sais
plus quoi donc il y a eu normalement une
commission
comme celle-là Haddock elle a une durée
de vie qui est de je crois un an et donc
il y a eu une G1 et une G2 puisqu'elle a
été reconduite j'ai été membre de ING 1
et pour être tout à fait honnête mon
assiduité allait en diminuant quand j'ai
compris que finalement le président
avait surtout une obsession sur deux ou
trois pays voilà et que c'était toujours
les mêmes observateurs enfin la même
catégorie de spécialistes qui étaient
invités qui étaient sur la Russie sur la
Chine ou qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
d'autres sur l'Inde voilà je précise
quand même que le Parlement européen
aujourd'hui il secoué par une affaire de
corruption ou qui touche d'abord le
groupe de Monsieur Glucksman le groupe
socialiste
il n'y a pas quelqu'un pour le moment il
y a personne du PPE il y aura personne
du je crois pas je sais pas puisqu'il je
pense pas je pense pas enfin en tout cas
pour le moment ce scandale ne touche que
des membres du groupe socialiste qui est
le groupe de Monsieur Glucksman
voilà et touche deux pays mais surtout
un le Qatar
dont elle n'a jamais parlé dans cette
commission voilà donc à sa place
j'espère qu'il vous répondra je me
poserai la question de savoir si j'ai
pas été à côté de la plaque les deux
premiers les deux premières années après
qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'ingérence
j'entendu effectivement ces chiffres qui
sont jetés par des experts mais qui
s'appuient sur rien écoutez chaque État
essaie de développer ce qu'on appelle le
soft power et d'avoir une influence dans
d'autres États vous m'avez parlé à
plusieurs reprises de mes invitations à
l'étranger mais la France fait pareil
vous le savez
la France fait pareil c'est à dire que à
moins que ça a été supprimé depuis que
avec des moyens beaucoup plus modestes
et je suis très heureux que la France
fasse pareil puisque vous avez au Quai
d'Orsay si ma mémoire est bonne parce
que j'ai passé des années à les recevoir
un programme qui s'appelle personnalité
d'avenir c'est ça personnalité d'avenir
qui est quoi qui est avec nos
ambassadeurs en quelques modestes de
plus en plus modestes crédit à leur
disposition pour inviter des
personnalités d'avenir dans leur pays ou
ces personnalités sont invitées une
semaine en général à découvrir la France
et à rencontrer un certain nombre de de
l'ordre des personnes qui avec qui
peuvent travailler donc tous les pays
font des invitations voilà je veux dire
tous les pays font des invitations et
heureusement que la France le fait
passait voilà après si vous voulez que
je vous dise
je veux raconter si vous le permettez
monsieur le Président mon histoire
personnelle très brièvement quel a été
le premier pays qui m'a invité à
l'étranger
et qu'elles ont été les pays qui m'ont
le plus invité à l'étranger
en août 2014 je fais la première
université des jeunes du RPR
ça me rajeunit pas
94 84 84 84 excusez-moi août 84 un mois
après je suis contacté par un conseiller
politique américain
qui me dit est-ce que vous voulez faire
partie du programme visiteurs ce
programme
visiteurs ce programme aujourd'hui c'est
Yang leaders il aura amélioré et alors
que je suis jeune député non jeune
délégué jeune c'est à dire rien du tout
j'ai rien du tout
le responsable américain m'invite pour
un mois un mois
aux États-Unis
programme obligatoire 4 jours à
Washington et puis après je choisis où
je veux aller 100 euros de perds par
jour pour découvrir les États-Unis et
pour la petite histoire à l'époque j'ai
travaillé dans la série et donc je fais
Washington pour les institutions et puis
après je fais Cleveland pour la
sidérurgie et j'assiste à la Convention
démocrate à
San Francisco comment sur démocrate de
1984 et le hasard fait que à cette
époque les cinq personnalités de la
formation à laquelle j'appartenais qui
sont sélectionnés comme quoi quand même
les Américains sont assez doués
s'appelle François Fillon
Michel Barnier
à l'intérieur et Michel Noir et Thierry
Mariani je suis le petit ce que je veux
dire par là c'est ce nombre ces voyages
là ont toujours existé je veux dire et
quand j'ai été dans cette maison pendant
25 ans le pays les pays qui m'ont
certainement le plus invité ça a été
Israël paix à mon ami
Eric Raoult qui est parti mais qui
organisait des voyages en Israël de
découverte des institutions et tout donc
si vous voulez je pense que c'est une
grave erreur pour vous que de présenter
que d'accepter des invitations à
l'étranger est une faute voilà il faut
qu'il y ait une transparence mais si on
prive désormais les représentants du
peuple de pouvoir voyager d'autant plus
que l'Assemblée nationale a c'est pas un
reproche c'est constant depuis un
certain nombre d'années de moins en
moins de un budget de plus en plus serré
vous allez finir par pas dépasser
Marseille et donc je vous comprends pas
pourquoi on met en place ces accusations
sur voilà
je pense qu'il faut garantir la
transparence
mais
la transparence doit vous permettre doit
permettre au parlementaire de voyager et
si vous permettez une suggestion que
j'ai déjà fait au Parlement européen
puisque quand madame mezzola a dit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire après le
catargage me permet de vous faire
monsieur le Président et Madame la
rapporteur une suggestion
quand nous sommes députés français ou
députés européens on doit remplir un
questionnaire pour la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
etc ou en nos demandes nos placements
qui théoriquement est censés débusquer
les conflits
il y a une question qu'on nous pose
jamais
et qui à mon avis est quand même
primordial on me demande la marque de ma
voiture en me demande quelle est la
valeur de mon portefeuille mais en nous
demande de pas si on a plusieurs
nationalités
or que ce soit au Parlement européen ou
que ce soit au Parlement français je
trouve que c'est quelqu'un qu'on doit
quelque chose qu'on doit connaître qui
est pas de malentendu connaître on a un
de nos un de vos collègues maintenant je
dois dire mais qui fut collègues mais il
y aura bib pour voilà même si je sais
qu'en ce moment il est en cours de
réélection
il va essayer d'être élu je prends mes
précautions mais qui très clairement dit
j'ai deux nationalités on a toute une
série de personnes de personnes qui que
ce soit au Parlement européen ou au
Parlement français ne le disent pas
voilà par exemple je dis au hasard quand
il y a un dossier sur le Maroc c'est
peut-être intéressant de savoir si la
personne a une nationalité d'un pays de
la zone qui peut être ami qui peut être
admis voilà et par exemple je le dis
avec le sourire ça fait
17 ans que je suis marié à une citoyenne
française d'origine russe j'aurais droit
à un passeport russe que j'ai refusé
voilà et je vous sugg c'est une
suggestion que j'ai fait au Parlement
européen je trouve que dans les
questionnaires de la Haute Autorité à
moins qu'on considère que la nationalité
c'est un chiffon qui est moins important
que la marque de sa voiture pour
connaître les conflits les ingérences
enfin les conflits d'intérêts ce serait
quand même quelque chose qu'on devrait
connaître très bien par contre on
n'avait pas du tout répondu à ma
question vous introduisez une confusion
entre ingérence ça pourrait être et
influence influence effectivement si on
vous invite ça peut être une influence
un gérant c'est tout à fait autre chose
et moi c'était la question que je vous
posais c'est est-ce que vous avez est-ce
que vous avez connaissance de la part de
la Russie ou de la Chine par exemple
d'ingérence au niveau de l'État français
sachant que vous l'aurez foutez mais la
plupart des experts que nous avons reçu
ici et quelquefois en huis clos et même
des services spécialisés nous ont
confirmé notamment que les principaux
pays qui faisaient des algérances pas
des influences était bien la Chine la
Russie et quelquefois l'Inde notamment
en termes électronique et Internet
la guerre économique dès que la première
les premières ingérence sont un
américaines de chinoises 3rus 4
allemandes voilà c'est le rapport si qui
a été publié à l'année dernière mais bon
tous les instituts en leur classement
est-ce que j'ai connaissance d'ingérence
non voilà vous auriez pu me poser la
question sur l'achat today puisque j'ai
été membre voyez je vais au devant de
vos questions puisque j'ai j'anticipe ça
viendra bon alors je la laisse pour
celui qui vaudra me la poser voilà non
j'ai pas connaissance d'ingérence
qu'est-ce que comment vous le définissez
une notion l'ingérence l'influence
c'était pour moi c'est défendre une
opinion déjà on est c'est d'après ce que
j'ai compris c'est c'est pas très clair
mais l'ingérence à savoir s'ingérer dans
les affaires d'un état pour changer la
politique de cet état non je suis désolé
j'ai pas connaissance d'ingérence russe
j'ai vu que l'Assemblée nationale avait
été attaquée hier par des hackers russes
je vous assure que voilà d'abord bien
sûr je le condamne et puis ensuite je
trouve voilà j'ai pas connaissance
d'autres ingérence russe en l'occurrence
très bien merci je vous remercie on va
passer la parole aux autres commissaires
je vous avais une question
de Monsieur Dumont
il est parti donc monsieur Tanguy donc
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Mariani vous avez mentionné très
précisément les dates des deux
ouvertures d'enquêtes enfin j'ai pas les
termes juridiques précis donc c'est que
j'ai bien noté mars 2021 et mars 2022
alors d'abord ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que j'apprends ça par le monde
voilà pour que vous compreniez
j'apprends ça par le monde donc je me
suis au monde qui est quand même comme
on dit en France au journal de référence
et qui en général est bien influence
voilà le monde dit que
le manque de mes deux-ville 21 donc de
mai 2021 a dit qu'il y avait non c'est
l'enquête qui aurait été ouverte en mai
2021 d'après le monde voilà
merci donc une deuxième enquête qui a
été ouverte aussi l'année dernière
une seule compris
de poser ma question il se trouve que la
semaine dernière nous avons reçu
notamment le cliff c'est mentionnerait
évidemment pas les les auditions sous
huis clos mais évidemment j'ai mentionné
donc c'est public le fait que dans les
raisons qui ont poussé à l'ouverture de
cette commission d'enquête du côté du
groupe rational puisque c'est son droit
de tirage j'ai fait remarquer notamment
sur l'affaire Fillon que nos concitoyens
certain nombre de commentateurs
pouvaient quand même s'interroger sur le
fait que en France il y avait des
enquêtes notamment l'affaire Fillon qui
avait été ouvert pendant une période
électorale cruciale avec des délais très
rapides avec des procédures des
procédures judiciaires qui ont pris un
cours très rapide et inversement des
procédures judiciaires par exemple
la procédure qui a été ouverte suite à
la commission d'enquête Marleix sur le
site entre guillemets le pacte de
corruption qui avait pu naître autour de
l'affaire Alstom en particulier
en cours depuis donc trois ans sans
qu'on sache vraiment où on en était donc
pour ce qui est de votre de des affaires
dont ont été mentionnés vous concernant
dont vous confirmer plusieurs choses que
j'ai entendu donc d'une part ce que vous
pouvez être un peu désert dans le
respect évidemment la séparation des
pouvoirs du fait que en dehors de ces
informations vous avez eu par la presse
vous n'avez reçu aucune convocation de
magistrac on a vu aucun entretien que
vous ne savez est-ce que vous avez
connaissance des faits précis qui vous
sont reprochés en dehors des
informations qui sont dans la presse et
cyclez bien compris aussi pour la
perquisition qui a eu lieu dans le
dialogue franco-reuse vous avez
sous-entendu ou dit que ce ne vous
concernait pas vous mais c'était une
perquisition qui concernait une tierce
personne et donc de cette perquisition
vous n'étiez pas ce qui est bien compris
concerné c'est ma première question
monsieur prise
excusez-moi je cherche je dis la date de
la perquisition c'était à peu près un an
je cherche je vais la retrouver parce
que l'inconvénient quand on a trop de
papiers je vous confirme alors d'abord
sur les deux enquêtes qui ont été
ouvertes il y a deux ans deux ans je
vous confirme que je n'ai rien
si le monde n'avait pas fait cet article
repris plus ou moins exactement parce
que le monde a écrit quand même des
choses intéressantes mais après ça
devient mise en examen ou je ne sais
quoi n'importe quoi dans d'autres
journaux je n'ai rien je n'ai jamais
reçu une convocation je n'ai jamais vu
un magistrat je n'ai rien voilà et je
répète pour la Xième fois que je rêve de
voir un magistrat ou un policier voilà
puisque j'ai rien à cacher
quant à la perquisition qui a eu lieu il
y a environ un an le 23 mars merci
2022 elle visait
d'après les policiers qui sont venus
notre ancien directeur Monsieur Roberts
qui a quitté le dialogue il y a environ
trois ou quatre ans puisque quand on a
eu des réductions de moyens forcément
je n'ai pas dit mais au départ on avait
indirecteur une attachée de presse et
puis une responsable chargée de
l'animation maintenant il nous reste
plus que la troisième en allant licencié
progressivement les deux autres et donc
la la
les services de police qui ont
perquisitionné nous ont dit qu'il
cherchait des bulletins de salaire de
Monsieur troubetzkoi j'avoue que je suis
quand même surpris parce que à un moment
c'était même avec des comment dire des
scanners pour voir s'il y avait pas des
choses planquées sous le plafond ou sous
le ou sous le parquet si monsieur
trubetzkoi qui avait quitté les
les parties le 1er avril 2017 voilà donc
il y a en réalité quasiment cinq ans
entre son départ et la perquisition
voilà donc est-ce que c'était pour
vraiment monsieur troubetzkoi ou est-ce
que c'était pour voir aussi ce qu'on
faisait à la limite ce serait le cas je
le comprendrais il suffit tout
simplement de le demander voilà mais
donc ça n'a aucun rapport avec moi
officiellement voilà
oui deuxième question qui n'a rien à
voir j'ai noté dans la création du
dialogue franco-russe donc qui se ferme
à ma part donc été créé un stigmation de
Monsieur Chirac et de de Monsieur
Poutine de mémoire en 2002 c'était bien
les éléments que monter indiqués
et en fait quand vous avez mentionné
liste non exhaustive
les cotisants les entreprises cotisantes
jusqu'en 2014 on retrouve en fait
l'essentiel des acteurs des grandes
infrastructures
énergies enfin de transport énergétique
je sais pas s'il y avait Renault enfin
qu'à des affaires que des affaires en
Russie enfin donc on retrouve puisque à
l'occasion de l'invasion de l'Ukraine la
vaseline légale de l'Ukraine par la
Russie un certain nombre de
d'entreprises françaises se sont
évidemment retirées du marché russe dans
des conditions qui restent à définir et
on s'est rendu compte aussi de
l'importance en fait des liens
économiques anciens datant pour
l'essentiel du mandat contredirez ce que
vous êtes un meilleur spécialiste que
moi ou d'autres ici si j'ai bien compris
du monde avec les demandes à Chirac
et finalement la question que je me pose
en dehors des actes d'ingérence dont a
parlé le président escanigogs et que sur
lequel je rejoins d'assurance dans des
actes hostiles du gouvernement ou de
d'institutions paragouvernementale
notamment sur les attaques les Internet
et compagnie mais moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on parle quand même d'un récit en
fait de l'histoire économique entre la
France et la Russie et que on relie les
événements et là c'est votre regard
aussi de spécialiste de ces relations on
relit les événements par la fin à la
lumière donc de l'invasion illégale de
l'Ukraine de l'annexion de la Crimée et
on ne relie pas les événements dans leur
vrai sens c'est à dire que après
l'effondrement de l'URSS
et l'arrivée au pouvoir de Vladimir
Poutine des liens économiques très forts
sont établies entre les différents
gouvernements français et la Russie
qu'on pouvait d'ailleurs critiquer à
l'époque et que un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques françaises de
différents parties on fait
essentiellement il faut bien le dire de
le visiblement de l'UMP de l'époque
travail autour de ces relations et que
on relie ces relations de d'une manière
qui n'ont pas qui sont peut-être
aujourd'hui mal intentionnés votre votre
regard là-dessus et notamment je pensais
une autre personnalité j'ai retrouvé
quand même pour préparer cette audition
le cadre Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Chevènement bon qui est une personnalité
politique imminente qui a eu des
responsabilités dans différents
gouvernements qui a été je crois envoyé
spécial d'ailleurs qui a soutenu
monsieur Macron c'est son droit je crois
même qu'il y a un accord électoral en
2022 pour faire élire des personnalités
liées à Monsieur Chevènement dans la
majorité et il a reçu la médaille je
vais pas dire une bêtise de ce que moi
je connais pas du tout le le spa
familier de le le le Lord pardon l'ordre
de l'amitié du président vladen Poutine
avec une reconnaissance personnelle de
Vladimir Poutine en avril 2017 et je
cite alors moi je parle par russe et je
le fais confiance à la traduction
monsieur Poutine aurait déclaré
j'aimerais exprimer ma gratitude à nos
amis étrangers qui ont reçu l'ordre de
l'amitié votre attitude y parle à
Monsieur Chevènement votre attitude
sincère et cordiale envers la Russie
s'exprime pour des actions concrètes
voilà bon moi je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire enfin c'est un discours aimable en
fin de personnalité monsieur levénement
beaucoup travaillé en tant que lutte
Belfort évidemment sur Alstom aussi bien
Alstom Transport kalstom energy je dis
d'autant plus que moi j'ai beaucoup de
respect à titre personnel pour Monsieur
Chevènement c'est pas du tout l'estime
de mon côté du cirque je ne sais pas que
ce n'est pas un adversaire politique
donc voilà donc moi je m'interroge et ça
ne remet pas du tout en cause les vrais
problèmes d'ingérence contre lequel il
faut lutter sur une relecture a
posteriori des relations économiques
anciennes entre la France et la Russie
merci monsieur le Président la France
était le premier employeur étranger en
Russie avant le début de cette guerre
première employeur étranger avec des
entreprises phares comme Auchan Leroy
Merlin dont on parle en ce moment mais
aussi Renaud etc c'est à dire que la
France effectivement
pas uniquement Jacques Chirac que ce que
en réalité depuis le général de Gaulle
on a de bons rapports et ça a continué
j'ai envie de dire jusqu'à Nicolas
Sarkozy inclut voilà on avait de bons
rapports avec la Russie et donc les
entreprises françaises se sont implantés
dans cette dans ce pays
madame Genevet qui en est maintenant la
députée doit connaître la Chambre de
commerce qui est l'une des plus
dynamiques la Chambre de commerce
franco-russe qui était l'une des plus
dynamiques avant les sanctions donc
oui effectivement c'est c'est un pays
avec lequel on a eu énormément
de relations après vous savez si on
revient aux événements plus récents
la question est de savoir quand est-ce
que les choses ont commencé à se
détériorer voilà moi je rappelle souvent
que tout ça commençait en 2013 parce que
ça a pas commencé le 24 février de
l'année dernière
ça a commencé en réalité en 2013 quand
l'Union européenne a voulu imposer un
traité à deux et non pas à 3 à l'Ukraine
voilà vous permettrez monsieur le
Président quand puisque j'avais
mentionné que j'avais été président de
France Ukraine à une époque dans les
souvenirs qui me resteront dans ma vie
il y a la rencontre que j'ai eu le 13
décembre avec Monsieur Nicolas Azarov
Premier ministre du crâne
qui m'expliquait alors je n'avais aucun
pouvoir qui s'imaginait que j'en avais
que si on ne voulait éviter une
catastrophe il fallait à tout prix faire
en sorte que le traité avec l'Europe
soit un traité non pas à deux mais à
trois c'est-à-dire Europe Russie Ukraine
pour
le traité économique et tout le monde
oublie que tout a débuté là-dessus
parce que le conflit entre guillemets ou
les désaccords internes aux Ukrainiens
sur ce traité dans débouché sur Maydan
Maïda n'a débouché je sentir aussi
désolé sur un coup d'État je vous
rappelle quand même tout le monde
l'oubli mais la conversation de Madame
nous land qui ce qui est enregistré où
elle dit dans ce gouvernement on mettra
un tel un tel et puis elle a quand même
cette phrase élégante taille fuck Europe
et en réalité on est aujourd'hui dans
une étape supérieure d'une
supplémentaire d'un conflit qui a qui a
démarré en 2013 au départ par un simple
accord économique
très bien monsieur Tanguy vous avez
terminé
alors entre-temps monsieur Dumont est
revenu comme il était dans l'ordre dans
l'ordre de prise de parole je propose de
vous passer la parole avant angélique
pardon si vous permettez que je rajoute
une phrase monsieur le Président vous
rajoutez vous souvent des phrases
excusez-moi mais très rapidement non
simplement parce que vous avez mentionné
Chevènement effectivement Chevènement a
participé à l'assemblée générale
d'ailleurs de notre dialogue franco-rue
en 2015-2016 voilà pour dire qu'il y
avait des personnalités qui étaient
aussi bien à gauche qu'à droite et dans
les voyages que nous avons organisés
tout est transparent c'est sur Twitter
il suffit de regarder les photos il y
avait les personnalités de gauche et de
droite merci Monsieur Dumont merci
monsieur le président madame le
rapporteur monsieur Mariani bonjour
vous avez pu évoquer dans votre propos
éliminaire différents voyages que vous
avez effectués je voudrais revenir pas
sur les voyages où vous vous avez été
invité en tant que tel en tant que
personne pour surveiller des scrutins
peu importe on va parvenir dessus ma
question est plutôt sur les déplacements
qui ont été effectués où vous pourriez
être considéré comme le chef de
délégation où vous ameniez différents
députés de différents groupes que ce
soit des députés nationaux ou des
députés européens
généralement en Syrie ou en Crimée
pouvez-vous nous dire d'une part si
c'était à votre propre initiative ou si
c'était
la puissance soit la Russie soit le
régime syrien qui vous demandait de
faire le gobetween d'être
l'intermédiaire entre les députés des
élus nationaux européens et le pouvoir
en place comment était choisi les
députés qui participaient comment
étaient financés c'est déplacement et
qu'elle était exactement votre rôle dans
ces déplacements en particulier sur
la région que j'évoquais qui est la
région de la Crimée et sur la Syrie je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur Dumont monsieur Mariani
ces deux problématiques différentes Siri
en réalité au début j'y suis allé avec
SOS chrétiens d'Orient
c'est-à-dire que je vous rappelle moi je
me souviens de c'était la même salle
mais de Madame Guigou qui nous annonçait
toutes les semaines la fin de la chute
de d'Assad et je préférais excuser moi
qui est le gouvernement qui a eu plutôt
qu'à voir el-kaïda ou plutôt al nostra à
la tête de la Syrie donc oui je suis
allé en Syrie
je sais pas cinq six fois de toute façon
moi je mets tout sur Twitter donc il
suffit de Kanté j'y suis allé à peu près
chaque année depuis depuis 2015 ouais
merci depuis 2015
j'ai l'honneur d'avoir été là à la fin
des combats à Alep au point que
d'ailleurs les journalistes qui étaient
avec nous peuvent en témoigner on est
resté bloqué sur le l'aéroport pendant
plusieurs heures parce que visiblement
les environs de l'aéroport avaient pas
été j'aime pas ce vocabulaire mais
nettoyer et qui restait encore des
représentants dans nostra donc oui la
Syrie j'y suis allé très clairement et
moi je pense qu'en politique excusez-moi
entre deux mots il faut choisir le
moindre moi j'adore tous ceux qui ont
rêvé des islamistes modérés ou plutôt
pendant des années sauf que pour tous
ceux qui connaissent la situation
syrienne à un moment c'était ou l'un ou
l'autre voilà et moi je préfère que le
gouvernement qui est en place à l'heure
actuelle reste plutôt que plutôt
qu'avoir un nouveau un gouvernement qui
servent de bastions islamistes
qui organisait donc je le répète seront
là au début on organisé avec SOS
chrétiens d'Orient après je sais plus
dans les 6 ou 7
combien on a fait avec eux combien on a
fait sans eux après
voilà comment je sélectionnais entre
guillemets ou choisissez je crois que
c'est votre terme pardon les les
protagonistes tout simplement parce
qu'il m'avaient dit qu'ils y étaient
intéressés pour venir voilà de toute
façon quand vous alliez en Syrie vous
étiez montré du doigt et vous aviez
droit à l'eau propre généralisée donc il
y avait pas énormément de candidats il y
a eu des gens de tous les partis
politiques sauf le rassemblement
national puisqu'à l'époque il n'était
pas un Assemblée nationale où il y en
avait non à l'époque non et donc en
réalité voilà qui payait nous nous parce
qu'en réalité
le la seule dépense c'est un pari
Beyrouth en avion Paris Berrut un avion
de l'époque on avait ça 400 euros voilà
Nico et après bien sûr que les locaux en
charge les transports et l'hôtel voilà
et en général ça se limitait à deux
nuits d'hôtel et
et au transport en me tend là par
exemple la copie de ma déclaration à
Monsieur Ferdinand Melun socramania
excusez moi si j'ai corps chez son nom
qui était comme chacun s'en souvient
déontologue à l'Assemblée nationale par
exemple du voyage du 10 novembre 2015 en
application de la décision du 6 avril
2011 qui prévoit l'obligation pour les
députés de déclarer les voyages
financiers financés par une personnalité
physique ou morale je vous signale forme
que je me rendrai en Syrie du 11 au 14
novembre avec Monsieur Nicolas Duick
Jean Lassalle Yannick Moreau et Michel
Voisin donc tout ça à chaque fois était
systématiquement signalé et d'ailleurs
en général vous voyez je mettais les
billets d'avion sont à nos frais les
frais d'hébergement ainsi que le
transport dans le cadre du programme
sont assurés par l'organisateur alors là
c'était donc un voyage sur les chrétien
d'Orient qui prenait en charge le
transport mais le transport c'est pas
Damas Beyrouth c'est une heure et demie
de route
c'est pas voilà donc
c'était et tout ça était entièrement
déclaré à partir du moment où ça a été
obligatoire d'ailleurs je le dis avec
humour parce que comme ensuite il y
avait une sorte de polémique de certains
députés en disant mais comment
l'Assemblée nationale a pu autorisé de
tels déplacements le déontologue se
sentait obligé de rajouter un paragraphe
en disant certes vous avez rempli les
obligations mais à titre personnel je ne
peux que vous déconseiller ce voyage ce
à quoi j'avais une lettre type en lui
disant oui que je ne peux que vous
déconseiller ce voyage qui peut avoir
une exploitation politique et dans ce
cas là on lui répondait la lettre en
disant comprenait acte qu'on avait
rempli toutes les obligations mais qu'on
le rassurer qu'on faisait de la
politique et qu'il que ce voyage est une
exploitation politique c'était plutôt le
but merci Monsieur Mariani monsieur
Dumont il a Crimée si vous permettez je
finis de répondre parce que merci
monsieur le Président la Crimée je crois
que je l'ai dit en réalité ça a été soit
à l'invitation des autorités soit les
premières missions étaient organisées
par le dialogue franco-russe
j'ai du monde
très bien nous allons passer la parole à
Madame génétique
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Marigny sont très intéressants
mais nous étions ici les ingérences
alors c'est vrai que la notion la limite
le curseur entre influence et ingérence
ça continue homme ça n'est pas une
limite précise enfin les éléments vont
nous avoir apportés sont essentiellement
de l'influence vous étonniez tout à
l'heure du secret quel secret dites-nous
on n'est pas là pour chercher des
secrets on est là pour rechercher des
ingérences c'est-à-dire des moyens de
pression des moyens de pression des
moyens qui peuvent changer votre
jugement donc on sait que ça peut
s'exercer sur des finances sur des
chercheurs sur des journalistes sur la
presse et sur des élus donc c'est ça que
nous recherchons les moyens de pression
qui ont pu s'exercer sur vous et je
voudrais donc vous poser quelques
questions très précis je voudrais
revenir au dialogue en Corus vous avez
cité
des éléments de budgétaires tout à
l'heure sont tout à fait fixer l'année à
moi j'ai pas bien saisi l'année donc
j'aurais voulu ça vous avez dit qu'il y
avait beaucoup de cotisants au départ
des Russes et des Français donc vous
n'avez plus les pièces justificatives
mais vous êtes sincèrement donc
j'imagine que vous nous allez nous dire
exactement ce qu'il en était donc
quelles étaient les montants des
cotisations on va dire avant 2014
puisque le dit qu'il y avait deux points
d'inflexion dans la perception de ces
cotisations puis après 2014 et puis on
va peut-être prendre cette dernière
année 2022 si vous en détenez les
chiffres donc déjà quels étaient les
cotisations de qui venaient-elles parmi
les cotisants notamment du côté russe
c'est ce qu'il y avait des politiques
d'autant que vous nous avez dit que
cette association avait pour objectif un
dialogue à la fois économique et
politique vous avez dit j'y reviendrai
j'ai pas entendu fait que vous y revenir
sur le plan politique donc vraiment qui
finance précisément cette association et
puis d'autre part qu'elles étaient ses
dépenses à quoi servait ce budget
qu'est-ce que vous financier avec ce
budget ça c'était ma première question
la deuxième question
puisqu'on recherche les éléments de
pression qui pourraient s'exercer sur
vous j'aurais voulu moi ça va parce que
vous avez dit que vous étiez allé à de
très nombreuses reprises en Russie on
comprend notamment en partie pourquoi
quelles sont les intérêts que vous
pouvez avoir là-bas quels sont les biens
immobiliers que vous pouvez détenir
quels sont les sociétés dans lesquelles
vous pourriez avoir peut-être que vous
avez créé revendu parce que ça fait
partie de la vie économique classique
quels sont peut-être les parts que vous
pouvez détenir dans des sociétés russes
qu'elles étaient l'objet éventuels de
ces sociétés et enfin donc pour revenir
au moyen de pression puisque vous étiez
au premier loge puisque vous êtes l'un
des élus qui est allé le plus souvent en
Russie vous avez interagi beaucoup avec
des hommes politiques russes quelles
étaient vos liens avec le parti de la
lumière Poutine Russie Unie le cas
échanges les liens ça peut être des
rendez-vous ça peut être pouvez-vous
nous éclairer sur les liens vous pouvez
avoir avec avec ce parti puisqu'on a vu
nous-mêmes nous Français nous avons fait
évolué le comportement de Vladimir
Poutine depuis
sa première prise arrivée au pouvoir en
2000 et puis aujourd'hui ces différents
allaient venues entre les différents
postes qu'il a détenus avez-vous vu un
moment une inflexion dans la manière
dont il interagissait avec nous on voit
bien que soyons clairs entre nous nous
avons un modèle français de société que
nous défendons qu'elle nous tenons je
pense que vous y tenez également donc à
travers le parti que vous dans lequel
vous êtes maintenant et puis le modèle
de société que défend monsieur Poutine
il me semble qu'il y a une différence
notable entre les deux et permettez-moi
de constater que à travers votre
parcours politique les rendez-vous que
vous avez eu les votes que vous avez
exprimées au Parlement européen je
m'interroge naturellement entre dans
l'expression vous avez fait de d'élus
est-ce que ce sont vos convictions
profondes avec la défense de la France
que vous exprimez à traverser votre ou
bien est-ce que ce sont des commandes
peut-être qui vous seraient faites
j'exagère un peu peut-être mais j'aurais
voulu que vous puissiez nous éclairer
sur nos C3 points le dialogue franco-rus
les intérêts que vous pouvez avoir en
Russie et les méthodes de pression
exercées sur vous je vous remercie merci
Madame génétique monsieur Mariani j'ai
passé l'âge j'ai jamais eu même très
jeune de commande voilà que les choses
soient très claires vous j'ai
l'impression à vous écouter que j'aurais
entendu certains pseudo spécialistes de
la zone qui procèdent par sous-entendu
je l'ai dit et je le répète je n'ai
jamais eu de bien en Russie jamais je
n'ai jamais eu de part de société jamais
monsieur vitekin qui est un journaliste
qui fait un bon boulot je crois qu'en
plus il parle plus long il parle bien
russe qui a enquêté qui a même demandé
si je pouvais avoir des parts un certain
nombre de personnes il y a rien je suis
désolé vous doutez que quand on devient
ministre quand on est représentant en
Afghanistan tout ça est un peu étudié
voilà
vous savez ce qui est très grave je
trouve désormais en France et qui a une
sorte de totalitarisme de la pensée
quand on défend des idées qui sont
conformes à la majorité ou à ce que
souhaite le gouvernement on a des
opinions quand on défend des idées
opposées on a des intérêts j'ai pas
d'intérêt mon seul intérêt c'est la
France moi c'est l'intérêt c'est de
savoir quelle est la politique étrangère
quels sont les liens qu'on doit avoir
avec l'étranger voilà aujourd'hui je
suis catastrophique je vois l'évolution
de la politique sous le président Macron
voilà la France est un pays de plus en
plus isolé j'ai la nostalgie de l'époque
oui ou la France par exemple du temps de
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2008 va faire la paix
n'attend pas la vie de l'Europe en 2008
quand il y a Georgi Russie j'ai la
nostalgie même de l'époque où Monsieur
Hollande avec Madame Merkel en 2014 a
obtenu un feu mal respecté et
aujourd'hui je vois que la France est
totalement absent donc je vous répond
catégoriquement je n'ai rien revendu
rien acheté rien etc et je mets au défi
qui que ce soit de prouver le contraire
ce qui est ce qui est terrible c'est
qu'on peut quand même s'intéresser à
quelque chose par conviction quoi mais
j'ai l'impression dans votre société
dans le modèle actuel que défense sous
gouvernement les convictions et les
opinions c'est quelque chose qui doit
être forcément intéressé voilà moi je
suis de la vieille école je sais pas de
la start-up nation et je tout simplement
je pense que la France a intérêt
historiquement à garder les relations
avec la Russie je pense que s'allier
aujourd'hui
systématiquement s'aligner pardon sur
les positions défendues par l'OTAN et
les et les États-Unis sont une
catastrophe pour notre pays c'est une
catastrophe en ce moment pour notre
industrie on le voit au prix oui mais je
réponds mais c'est une question
politique nous égarons pas
mais
en politique c'est il y a quand même de
temps en temps il y a des opinions quoi
moi je veux bien qu'on m'interroge sur
mes intérêts puisque c'est toujours le
mot à chaque fois que j'ai mais quand
j'en ai pas voulu dans ce cas là je vous
réponds plus à rien quoi voilà
je vous réponds sur notre part est-ce
que j'en avais des relations avec avec
le parti de Poutine la réponse est oui
je suis allé plusieurs fois mais en tant
que en tant qu'UMP ou républicain si ma
mémoire est bonne ce que je t'ai pas au
rassemblement national
au congrès de yedinaraci ce qui est le
parti Russie après excusez-moi je me
permets quand même de me souvenir si
mémoire est bonne que la première
personne qui est manuel Macron a reçu un
grand de pompe au palais de Versailles
c'était un certain Vladimir Poutine
d'accord non non mais voilà je vous
réponds à vos questions oui je suis allé
deux ou trois fois au congrès de
yedinaraci le parti de Poutine oui parce
que j'étais invité j'ai même été invité
à d'autres congrès ou je suis pas allé
voilà parce que je vais pas vous savez
c'est toujours pareil quand vous
intéressez un pays ou des fois vous vous
avez de multiples invitations parce que
vous êtes
identifié comme interlocuteur voilà donc
oui je suis allé deux trois fois et je
le regrette pas et je le répète que je
sache
le président actuel ou l'ancien
président ont eu de nombreux rapports et
ma première rencontre personnelle avec
Monsieur Poutine ça a été quand on m'a
demandé de lui faire visiter mais je
crois qu'il était plus président de la
République il n'était plus Premier
ministre de lui faire visiter le Salon
du Bourget chose que j'ai fait avec
Édouard long avec Edward pendant Longuet
Gérard Longuet merci avec Gérard Languet
qui était ministre de la Défense et moi
j'étais ministre des Transports voilà
et donc je pense que donc j'ai répondu à
vos questions vous en avez j'en ai loupé
une
des financement des fr j'en profite pour
dire que quand j'étais effectivement au
congrès de yedinaraci le responsable des
relations parce qu'on m'avait demandé
tout à l'heure quels sont les politiques
russes que je connais bien par exemple
Constantin cosatchev qui à l'époque
était chargé des Relations
Internationales de Russie unie est
toujours lui président de la commission
étrangère des Affaires étrangères du
Sénat les chiffres pour le dialogue
franco-rus
époque de gloire si je fais un époque ad
d'abondance avant que j'arrive
762000 euros de cotisations russes et
cette année-là un peu moins de 100.000
euros de cotisation française
2011 2011
200 c'est l'arrivée de Yakounine
c'est-à-dire que c'est l'arrivée du
président du co-président Yakounine à
partir de mon arrivée donc 2012 les
Russes
je l'ai retrouvé maître 215 243 et
mettent 150 et les Français 159000 euros
mais posé la question qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de tout ça tout simplement à
l'époque je le répète le loyer c'était
aux alentours de 240
000 euros ou 220 000 euros excusez-moi
j'ai pas retrouvé les chiffres enfin ça
change pas grand chose voilà et d'autre
part il y avait du personnel c'est à
dire qu'il y avait un directeur qui
était monsieur trubetzkoi qui était
salarié aux alentours de entre 6 et 7000
euros une attachée de presse qui était
madame kamanskaya qui était salarié aux
alentours de 4000 euros et une autre
personne qui s'appelle Rina Dubois qui
est d'ailleurs la seule qui reste
aujourd'hui au dialogue franco-russe qui
fait office de ce qui fait voilà puisque
on a plus les moyens de pioche quelqu'un
d'autre qui était payé 2000 euros voilà
donc
2000 2012 donc je vous l'ai dit 2013
c'est une année un peu exceptionnelle
j'ai pas trouvé les participations
françaises mais les Russes avaient mis
beaucoup d'argent
parce que c'était on avait fait un grand
colloque avec le Medef c'est d'ailleurs
comme je dis tout à l'heure la dernière
grande manifestation où il y avait
531000 euros de participation les
dernières années malheureusement vous
voyez si je prends les chiffres que j'ai
retrouvé sont beaucoup plus modestes
2017 c'est 100 000 2018 c'est 100 000
alors c'est essentiellement pareil des
entreprises de transport
2020 c'est 151 000 et si on cherche les
dernières années c'est-à-dire celle où
en est aujourd'hui
laisser le temps de trouver la bonne
colonne
2020 je l'ai dit c'est 151000
2021 c'est 250 000 et depuis
2022 il y a
attendez je vais pas vous dire de
bêtises
je crois à peu près 50 000
je voudrais pas me tromper
c'est compliqué parce qu'il y a une
partie des documents qu'on a plus pour
les raisons que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure mais c'est 50000 en gros pour
cette année voilà c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui si vous le voulez quelle
est la situation du dialogue
franco-russe il nous reste à payer 70
000 euros ou 60 000 euros du loyer du
des Champs-Élysées qui sont toujours
impayés puisque c'était une société
gestima qui nous fait gentiment crédit
et on a à peu près la même somme en
caisse qui nous permet entre autres de
de faire les vidéos qu'on fait de
salariés
la collaboratrice etc
est-ce que j'ai répondu précisément
votre micro
[Musique]
russe une toute dernière question
au cours des différents mandats que vous
avez exercé j'entends que vous avez vous
dit d'avoir effectivement tout déclaré
ce qui n'est pas toujours facile pour
vous-même ou pour l'entourage et pas que
vous il y a des gens aussi qui étaient
avec vous vous êtes un observateur fin
de tout ce dialogue franco-rus au sens
propre du terme à pas au sens de
l'association
avez-vous observé de la part
de russe alors sont-ils politiques pas
politiques peu importe des souhaits de
pouvoir repérer
des personnes qui jugeaient d'intérêt
côté français pour faire exercer une
pression toujours on voit bien
aujourd'hui on voit bien que Monsieur
Poutine a un modèle notamment de société
de gouvernance à imposer donc vous êtes
un observateur bien placé je pense pour
pouvoir le dire avez-vous observé
peut-être même un changement
comportement depuis soit 2008 la Géorgie
soit 2014 la première invasion de
l'Ukraine soit 2022 plus récemment
quelles sont les tentatives
de pression sous forme toute forme qu'on
peut connaître deux cadeaux de
rendez-vous d'invitation que vous avez
pu observer qui peut-être ne vous
concerne pas vous êtes encore une fois
un observateur bien placé
excusez-moi j'ai un peu trop de papier
je précise le chiffre je vais répondre à
votre question mais le chiffre exact du
loyer effectivement c'est 120000 euros
pour le dialogue et 120000 pour RZD
c'est à dire que le plateau que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est 240 000
euros voilà je précise que c'était sur
les Champs-Élysées ce qui explique le
voilà je reviens à votre question est-ce
que j'ai eu des pression non je vais
vous faire moi non j'ai pas observé de
pression mais je vais vous dire quand
vous amenez en mission en Crimée ou
ailleurs des gens c'est que par
définition ce sont vos amis on fait pas
de pression sur les amis
voilà
on fait la pression sur des gens qui
vous menacent des gens voilà donc j'ai
pas de pression je suis désolé voilà
après
voilà de toute façon c'est un secret
pour personne que j'ai toujours milité
pour des relations
d'amitié entre ces deux pays je persiste
et je répète je pense que c'est
l'intérêt de la France voilà donc il y a
pas de pression à mener sur moi pour que
je m'intéresse à la Russie en plus comme
je l'ai mentionné j'ai aussi des
attaches personnelles puis bon j'ai en X
années j'ai plein d'amis là-bas y
compris dans la Communauté française
vous avez vous exercez un très beau
poste que j'ai agirais moi aussi pendant
5 ans c'est l'occasion aussi de
rencontrer des Français à Moscou qui
sont attachants qui sont devenus des
amis qui peut-être par moments sont pas
politiquement corrects mais par exemple
des Xavier Moreau d'autres sont des gens
pour qui j'ai une certaine estime voilà
merci Monsieur Mariani même je n'étais
vous avez terminé nous avions des prises
de parole monsieur Brun il est plus là
madame clapot
je garde la parole quelques secondes
pour vous indiquer qu'un vote solennelle
aura lieu en hémicycle sans doute après
18h et que dans ce cas je serais sans
doute obligé de suspendre la séance pour
que nous puissions aller voter une mais
ne reviendrons je laisse la parole à
Manon clapot
[Musique]
comment vous êtes intervenu
en soutien ou au contraire en combat de
ces sanctions
excusez-moi allez-y je tiens la voir à
vous dire que quand vous êtes député
français ou européen vous avez
exactement le même poids sur la décision
des sanctions c'est à dire nul
je rajoute deuxièmement que en tant que
parlementaire il faut toujours
s'interroger sur comment est défini la
nomenclature des sanctions et là vous
apercevrez que la France se fait à
chaque fois avoir je prends un exemple
en 2014 on a sanctionné tous les
produits beaucoup de produits agricoles
c'est certainement très dangereux les
pommes ou etc par contre la passe
sanctionner le spatial spatial c'est pas
militaire vous pensez c'est pas
stratégique pourquoi parce que les
États-Unis avaient besoin de la
coopération avec la Russie donc
premièrement on n'est jamais interroge
malheureusement vous en doutez en
intervient pas du tout sur les sanctions
je cherche
désespérément si je l'ai retrouvé quand
même je me permets de rappeler que ce
Parlement a adopté le 28 avril 2016
à mon initiative
une résolution
qui s'intitulait invitant le
gouvernement de pas renouveler les
mesures restrictives et les sanctions
économiques imposées par l'Union
européenne à la Fédération de Russie
vous me demandez qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
pour sur ces sanctions je les ai en
doutais je les ai combattus et donc ça
par exemple c'est une résolution dont
vous savez comme moi que au Parlement ça
n'a qu'une valeur symbolique mais c'est
à ma connaissance la seule résolution
sur la Cinquième République qui est
passée avec la vie contraire du
gouvernement
une résolution qui avait été déposée par
54 signataires
Thierry Mariani Damien Abad Bernard à
coyé je vais pas vous faire la liste
et qui a quand même au final était
adopté avec des voix qui venaient aussi
bien madame Bechtel je crois qu'elle
était avec Monsieur Chevènement
voilà des voies socialistes
des voies
des voix de la gauche démocratique des
voix des non inscrits puisqu'il y avait
monsieur Collard et Madame Marion
Maréchal-Le Pen et puis 45 voix des
républicains voilà donc j'aurais pas la
cruauté de rappeler Christian Jacob
François Fillon et bien d'autres et donc
à l'époque
j'avais présenté cette résolution pour
faire en sorte c'est le scrutin 1267 de
la première séance du 28 avril 2016 donc
je m'étais opposé à ces sanctions au
niveau du Parlement français et je
continue à m'opposer au niveau du
Parlement européen
je cherche le Verseau de cette page
parce que je persiste à dire que ces
sanctions sont pour notre économie un
suicide aujourd'hui nous alors pareil là
aussi d'abord posez-vous la question de
savoir
c'est très intéressant j'ai jamais
vraiment pu avoir la réponse y compris
au niveau européen parce que les
sanctions décidées par la France elles
sont décidées elles sont en semis les
sanctions européennes
mais comment sont choisis les sanctions
européennes
vous constaterez qu'à chaque fois c'est
choisi pour ne surtout pas gêner les
États-Unis je prends un exemple
le nucléaire civil bien sûr le nucléaire
civil n'est pas dans les sanctions
pourquoi devinez qui en a besoin
voilà et donc en réalité vous apercevez
que les sanctions à mon avis sont un
instrument contre la Russie certes mais
qui se retourne aussi contre les
États-Unis est-ce que la Russie est très
pénalisée la réponse soyons honnête dans
l'immédiat pas trop mais je pense qu'à
terme oui voilà à terme oui la première
année vous avez vu comme moi que
la hausse du cours des cours des
matières premières a fait que finalement
ils ont été beaucoup moins gênés
financièrement que ce que certains
espéraient pas la cruauté de rappeler
notre ministre de l'économie qui disait
qu'il allait mettre l'économie russe à
genoux mais mais sur le long terme elle
se rend certainement pénalisée le seul
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui je pense
que ils ont compris qu'il y avait
d'autres clients que l'Europe et petit à
petit se retournent vers eux donc moi je
persiste à dire que ces sanctions vont
autant nous pénaliser à la sortie que
elles vont pénaliser la Russie et que à
la sortie comme d'habitude il y aura un
seul grand gagnant
merci Monsieur pour une autre question
alors je cite de mémoire mais les
sanctions agricoles ça a été les
contre-sensions de la Russie contre des
sanctions et pas des sanctions agricoles
c'est souvent un contresens qui est fait
mais bon à vérifier vous avez répondu
partiellement mais vous n'avez pas
totalement répondu sur les activités du
dialogue franco-russe et vos prises de
position en dehors de cette activité qui
est purement parlementaire dans le coeur
de du mandat parlementaire café dialogue
franco-russe par rapport aux sanctions
je rappelle qu'il y avait une campagne
pas tout à fait affichée de la Russie
pour faire tomber ses sanctions
je me souviens bien qu'il y avait quand
même toute une influence je pense que
c'est de l'influence peut-être pas de la
gérance mais pour que la France l'Union
européenne renonce à ses sanctions
on a fait on a rien de fait de spécial
on a expliqué que c'était une sanction
stupide mais c'est l'intérêt de la
France moi que je défends je me moque
excusez-moi de l'intérêt des autres
États l'intérêt de la France aujourd'hui
c'est d'avoir des entreprises
françaises à l'étranger qui créent des
emplois en France notamment je le répète
on était le premier investisseur
étranger premier employeur pendant
étranger et on était investisseur dans
de très nombreux secteurs voilà donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a rien fait de
spécial façon tout ça est transparent on
a fait effectivement des conférences ou
si ma mémoire est bonne même monsieur
Chevènement à l'époque était d'accord
pour dire qu'il fallait supprimer ses
sanctions et je persiste à le dire après
sur mes votes au Parlement européen
je
si vous voulez parce que j'ai vu
récemment encore un article de
Camille c'est L'Express Camille vigogne
je crois de l'Express vous savez au
Parlement européen les résolutions par
moment elle peut madame Gentet revient
c'est génial c'est bien parce que c'est
ce que vous m'aviez posé la question de
mes votes au Parlement européen
madame legrid qui a siéger c'est très
bien que les résolutions par moments
peuvent faire plusieurs pages et
quand on a une résolution qui dit il
faut que tout le monde soit heureux il
faut peut-être lire les pages
et donc on a fait l'objet récemment au
niveau du rassemblement national d'une
étude de nos votes par hebdomadaire donc
qui reprenait quatre cinq résolutions en
disant pourquoi ils ont voté ceci et
cela j'en prends quelques-unes
simplement si vous le permettez puisque
ça répond indirectement à la question de
Madame gente qui me demandait mes votes
par exemple la résolution de
septembre-novembre 2022 dans laquelle
nous nous sommes abstenus ou en refuser
une nouvelle aide à l'Ukraine pourquoi
parce que la Cour des comptes de l'Union
européenne le 23 septembre 2021 dans un
rapport qui est en français que vous
trouvez sur le site de la Cour des
comptes européen de la Cour des comptes
européennes dit on a versé à l'Ukraine
17 milliards 17 milliards d'euros c'est
avant la guerre et tout ça servit
en grande partie enrichir la grande
corruption voilà est-ce qu'il faut sans
cesse donner plus je vous rappelle quand
même tout le monde a oublié qui était
Yulia Timochenko parce que le système
pour fabriquer des icônes tout le monde
oublie par exemple pendant la Révolution
orange madame yugiatimochenko était
présenté comme aujourd'hui monsieur
Zelinski comme un héros je ne sais plus
combien d'années après elle a passé en
prison deuxième résolution
par exemple sur en nous sommes abstenus
là aussi pourquoi madame la journaliste
avait dit sur l'escalade de la guerre
d'agression menée par la Russie mais
parce que tout simplement quand on lit
la résolution il y a dedans qui est
demandé dans cette résolution un embargo
immédiat est total sur les importations
de combustibles russes fossiles
d'uranium rappelez-moi comment une
partie de nos centrales nucléaires
tourne
avec de l'uranium qui revient de qui
revient de rosatum alors je sais que
voilà donc est-ce que moi je vote déjà
le parc nucléaire à quelques problèmes
en France je vais pas voter une
résolution qui entre parenthèses a été
votée par Madame Loiseau et ses amis qui
risque de mettre en danger un peu plus
le parc nucléaire français voilà et puis
je peux vous par exemple le troisième
exemple et puis j'arrêterai là pourquoi
on a voté contre un tribunal spécial
pour le crime d'agression contre
l'Ukraine en janvier de 23 bah parce que
tout simplement il demande à l'article
15 d'adopter
que les certains états et la France est
nommée acceptent les amendements de
Kampala c'est-à-dire en fait que nos
concitoyens puissent être jugés par
cette cour je vous rappelle que le
gouvernement français présidé par le
madame borne et contre cette convention
voilà donc paradoxalement par moment on
se retrouve à voter la même chose que
demande le gouvernement français parce
que c'est l'intérêt de la France et le
groupe qui représente la majorité au
Parlement européen vote contre les
règlements les intérêts français ou la
position du gouvernement français à
moins qu'il ait pas lu jusqu'au bout les
résolutions
nous avions donc après une prise de
parole une prise de questions de
Monsieur ménager je suis ménagé merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur Mariani
moi j'avais une question assez simple
vous êtes vu dans tous les médias comme
l'homme politique et les liens les plus
rapprochés avec avec la Russie mais il y
a d'autres hommes politiques que vous
avez cité notamment l'ancien Premier
ministre François Fillon pourtant lui
aucun article de presse aucun média
semble l'impliquer ou sous-entendre un
certain nombre d'ingérences russes de
par son intermédiaire pourtant il a été
premier ministre pourtant lui peut-être
encore plus que vous vous signez entre
commencer ministre bien entendu mais
entre le Premier ministre je pense qu'il
détient un certain nombre d'informations
que que vous n'avez pas en votre
possession il a été je crois de mémoire
dans deux conseils d'administration
jusqu'à bien entendu la crise et la
guerre en Ukraine ou d'admissionné donc
des postes rémunérés à votre différence
quand vous expliquez cette différence de
traitement et le fait que lui n'est que
rarement voir jamais à ma connaissance
j'ai pas eu d'artistes dans ce sens
inquiété du moins suspecté alors que
vous vous êtes manière très régulière
merci pour votre question
il y a un moment où quand ça tire dans
tous les sens certains font profil bas
quoi voilà moi je soutiens mes ceux qui
à mon avis en
intérêts ont des intérêts communs avec
la France voilà Monsieur Fillon
aujourd'hui est absent je dirais pas de
mal de lui mais j'étais dans son
Couvernement et je respecte comme
Nicolas Sarkozy ce moment de mon
parcours voilà je constate simplement
qu'effectivement comme vous l'avez
rappelé ils ont été tous les deux l'un a
été dans des conseils d'administration
l'autre je crois plus ou moins eu un
contrat avec un oligarque moi je n'ai
rien eu parce que je n'ai rien demandé
et rien souhaité voilà c'est tout quand
j'ai été battu je suis retourné dans le
Vaucluse voilà j'ai vendu ma maison à
Valréas et j'ai essayé de trouver un
autre boulot je vais faire même j'avais
même été si vous voulez savoir des
marchés par une société j'ai jamais su
qui c'était mais je pense que c'était
makoiri pour la privatisation des
aéroports dans certains pays de l'Est et
à un moment j'ai reçu une lettre de la
compagnie que je garde pieusement me
disant vu vos rapports avec la Syrie la
compagnance a émis un avis négatif donc
le problème c'est quand on quand on a
par moment certains partis ou certaines
opinions qui ne vont pas dans le sens de
la majorité après on se retrouve un peu
marqué ou faire rouge voilà j'ai rien
souhaité de la Russie je laisse ceux qui
ont choisi de de d'accepter ces postes
j'aurais pu l'accepter peut-être qu'un
jour je l'accepterai je le dis pas parce
que pour le moment on m'a je n'ai rien
cherché donc on m'a rien proposé et
effectivement certains aujourd'hui dans
tous les partis politiques veulent faire
oublier quelle relation ils ont eu avec
certains pays
très bien merci Monsieur Mariani
monsieur
monsieur Tanguy
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Mariani on dans l'ordre initial de de
nos de nos auditions on aurait dû mais
c'est de ma faute parce que j'étais
malade recevoir Monsieur Ripert
ambassadeur de France en Russie qui lors
des élections et comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure le but de notre commission c'est
de voir le problème des ingérences et
donc dans le cas du processus électoral
français monsieur Ripert a fait une
déclaration qui avait quand même été
largement
commenté 10 ans que sa connaissance en
tant qu'ambassadeur de France en Russie
il avait eu connaissance de personnalité
française qui avait reçu ou qui était
parti je ne sais plus le thème qui avait
été employé exactement avec des valises
de billets sous-entendants que ces
personnes étaient évidemment là dans le
cadre d'une ingérence comme l'a dit et
notre collègue génétique tout à l'heure
c'est à dire dans le but de faire
changer ou de prendre des opinions en
lien avec l'argent qu'ils avaient reçu
vous allez à l'expérience de
l'expérience que vous avez des relations
de du personnel
diplomatique aussi français qu'est-ce
que quand vous l'avez entendu cette
déclaration est-ce que ça vous a inspiré
quelque chose est-ce que vous avez un
commentaire à faire sur cette
déclaration qui pourrait nous aider dans
nos travaux
merci je crois de votre commission si
j'ai bien compris Val auditionner
bientôt je suis plus un spécialiste du
code de procédure pénale mais c'est
l'article 30 mémoire est bonne ou
peut-être qui oblige à 40 merci merci
voilà si la connaissance de fidélités en
tant qu'ambassadeur il a l'obligation de
les signaler voilà j'ai trouvé cette
déclaration extrêmement choquante parce
que où on va jusqu'au bout et dans ce
cas là on a des preuves on a des noms et
on avance ou sinon c'est salir pour
salir vous voyez c'est comme si moi je
disais j'ai connu dans ma vie beaucoup
d'ambassadeurs qui en profitaient etc
c'est dégueulasse c'est faux mais ça
laisse la suspice ça jette la suspicion
sur tout le corps je me souviens aussi
d'ancien ministre qui avait expliqué que
il avait connu un ministre de la Culture
si maman est bonne dans certains pays du
Maghreb qui allait souvent pour diverses
raisons je crois que c'était Luc Ferry
qui m'aimerait bonne voilà et pareil
quoi où on a des accusations et on donne
les noms et j'espère que c'est ce qui
fera ou alors on se tait voilà je n'ai
pas connaissance pour répondre à votre
question de personnalité politique qui
sont repartis avec des valises
mais j'espère que Monsieur Ripert vous
dira de qui s'agissait
si ça existe merci Monsieur Mariani
monsieur Tanguy vous avez terminé je
pense qu'il y avait pas d'autres
questions à toi aussi donc je vais te
laisser je vais vous laisser la parole
le rapporteur je terminerai par deux
questions que j'ai gardées ce qui nous
pourra nous permettre peut-être d'être
directement sur le vote solennelle je
l'espère
oui sur les JO dans l'hémicycle madame
la rapporteur je laisse la parole
le président de me passer la parole donc
ça a été rappelé notamment par notre
collègueil les concepts d'influence
d'interférence d'ingérence ne sont pas
identiques et recouvrent des réalités
qui a certains égards peuvent être
différentes je dirais et en un temps
cité et en nature mais il y a quand même
un
continent par ailleurs vous avez
beaucoup prenez la transparence les
déclarations préalables en cas de
déplacement de voyage
d'accueil positif réservé à des
invitations et là-dessus nous ne pouvons
qu'être d'accord avec voilà les
obligations de transparence et l'intérêt
que cela apporte et par ailleurs les
votes les déclarations politiques les
prises de position que l'on prend que
les hommes et les femmes politiques
prennent écrivent sont connus donc il
est tentant de faire un parallèle bien
évidemment entre les déclarations que
l'on fait au nom de la transparence et
puis ensuite ce que l'on dit ce que l'on
vote ce que l'on déclare ce que ce on
écrit et donc là force est de constater
j'espère que ça n'est pas vous faire
injure que les dire cela que
votre
intérêt soutenu pour la Russie et pour
le suivi des actualités et des activités
du régime russe vous amène à dans vos
déclarations dans dans vos votes dans
vos tribunes à être
aligné assez régulièrement et par les
votes assez systématiquement aligné je
ne dis pas autre chose mais qu'il y a
voilà de ce point de vue là comme une
influence qui se traduit par des votes
par des prises de position par des
opinions des opinions certains tout à
fait
exprimer selon le régime de la liberté
d'opinion qui existe dans notre pays
bien évidemment et qui existe dans tous
les pays de l'Union européenne mais qui
sont alignés et qui corroborent et
relais
les activités les éléments de langage et
les
politiques mises en place par le régime
de Vladimir Poutine donc ça c'est quand
même quelque chose dont je pense il vous
serait difficile de contester la réalité
donc je voulais simplement vous demander
comment vous vous réagissez à cela et
est-ce que vous pouvez considérer
qu'effectivement vous êtes souvent en
rappel des
positions
élément de langage et autres
souhaits exprimer par le régime
merci
je sais pas ce que souhaite le régime je
sais que qui est en réalité le
gouvernement je sais ce que je crois
voilà c'est tout donc moi je défends mes
convictions voilà excusez-moi je n'ai
jamais été rémunéré par la Russie
vous êtes député vous avez été député
européenne vous savez que par exemple
on a découvert à l'occasion de des votes
pour la confirmer comme comme
commissaire éventuel madame sylvie
Goulard on a découvert qu'elle touchait
10000 euros d'une fondation américaine
10000 euros moi j'ai jamais rien touché
et elle vous lui posez pas la question
pourquoi dans ces positions elle est
alignée sur ce que demande les
États-Unis vous avez un de vos collègues
que je respecte je dirais BH
qui est au groupe Renaissance qui a été
qui a travaillé au Hudson Institute ou à
l'Atlantique kansil moi j'ai jamais été
salarié par des signes tanks américains
voilà vous voilà voilà je vais pas vous
faire la liste parce que voilà je veux
pas mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est qui est extraordinaire c'est que
si on a on est 10000 euros par exemple
ça c'est pareil ou salarié de certaines
fondations américaines tout le monde
trouve ça normal
voilà et si on me défend en ayant jamais
été salarié de quoi que ce soit des
positions qui sont pas dans l'air du
temps
effectivement tout le monde te dit mais
mon Dieu pourquoi il a une opinion
divergente je pense qu'en ce moment dans
notre pays excusez moi la liberté
d'opinion recule insidieusement voilà et
que on a le droit d'avoir d'autres
positions je suis prêt à défendre tous
mes votes
je m'en a pas le temps mais je le répète
et vous étiez une je le sais une députée
sérieuse au Parlement européen quand
j'ai une résolution je regarde pas que
le titre voilà voilà et je répète je
reprends mon exemple quand le groupe
Renaissance au Parlement européen vote
l'arrêt de de livraisons de nucléaires
civils dans les pays européens ça veut
dire qu'on met une flèche de plus dans
l'industrie nucléaire française mais moi
je pense d'abord l'intérêt de mon pays
voilà et donc je maintiens tous ces
choix personne me dit que tu as mes
éléments de langage
c'est vrai que j'ai moins invité sur
certaines chaînes d'information
mais mais je pense aussi que si vous
avez l'impression que
je suis le premier soutien où je ne sais
quoi de la Russie c'est peut-être aussi
parce que certains qui en ont profité à
une époque sont maintenant aux abricots
voilà moi j'ai j'ai toujours défendu mes
convictions je continuerai les défendre
et j'en suis plutôt fier voilà si vous
souvenez
mon premier voyage aussi conoclaste ça
avait été d'être de conduire les
dernières missions en Irak avant
l'invasion américaine en 2002 et à
l'époque aussi c'était condamné par tout
le monde
très bien monsieur Mariani donc on
m'indique que nous avons un vote donné
dans 5 minutes s'il y a plus trop de
questions j'avais quand même une
dernière question si vous pouvez
répondre très rapidement on note depuis
peu au Parlement européen l'arrivée de
collaborateurs russe on m'indique que
vous avez depuis peu une assistante
russe madame Anastasia Petrova que vous
pouvez nous dire sur ce sujet
Anastasia Petrova elle était étudiante
en communication politique à Nanterre
elle cherchait un stage désespérément je
quand vous êtes russe c'est pas facile
de trouver un stage je l'ai pris en
stage Béné quasi bénévole 500 euros je
crois au Parlement européen manque de
bol à la signé son stage la veille du
covid c'est-à-dire que ces six premiers
mois de stage elle est restée dans son
cagibi chez elle à
Bruxelles je lui renouvelle et son stage
pour qu'elle fasse un vrai stage à la
demande de sa fac je lui renouvelé la
cette fois fait un mois de stage réel
puisque le covid continuait j'ai demandé
au Parlement si je pouvais la prolonger
on m'a répondu que non il fallait dans
ce cas là que je l'embauche comme elle
était excellente je l'ai embauché à
contrat à durée indéterminée mais je
vous signale qu'il y a plein de groupes
qui ont des collaborateurs d'origine
russe voilà je veux dire cette jeune
femme parle français a fait des études
en France voilà et pour
très bien écoutez je vous remercie pour
cette réponse je propose s'il n'y a plus
de questions de
terminer la séance de lever la séance le
terme exact merci à tous et donc je vous
donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour d'autres auditions